mes chers collègues nous représenter un
après-midi les auditions de la
commission d'enquête sur le coût de la
vie dans les collectivités territoriales
régies par les articles 73 et 74 de la
Constitution afin de conclure notre
cycle d'audition nous allons entendre
aujourd'hui Monsieur Jean-François
carinco ministre délégué chargé des
Outre-mer monsieur le ministre je vous
souhaite la bienvenue et je vous
remercie de prendre le temps de répondre
à notre invitation je vais vous passer
la parole pour une intervention des
mineurs qui précédera notre échange sous
forme de question de réponse à commencer
par celle de notre rapporteur je vous
remercie également de les regarder tout
autre intérêt public ou privé de nature
à influencer vos dés de vos déclarations
alors j'ai un petit doute est-ce que je
dois faire préciser sur mon ensemble de
la délégation ou juste au ministre juste
au ministre
très bien auparavant je vous rappelle
que l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relatifs relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
additionnées par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous invite donc monsieur le
ministre à lever la main droite et à
dire je le jure
je vous remercie et je vous passe la
parole
je suis le président Monsieur rapporteur
messieurs les députés
je voudrais dire que je suis content
d'être là puisque j'ai donné un avis
favorable à la surprise d'un certain
nombre de personnes à la création de
cette commission d'enquête et je m'en
suis tout à fait content
quel que soit les difficultés de
transport tous les jours que ce soit
Paris ou lors de mes nombreux
déplacements à la rencontre des acteurs
locaux
il y a de la grandeur dans la petite est
dans les petites choses dans la moindre
chose il y a de la grandeur à condition
qu'à l'horizon il est un but ils étaient
mes césaires c'est ce que j'essaye de
faire
l'objectif c'est de rétablir la
confiance d'impulser une nouvelle
dynamique un nouvel élan a même de faire
rayonner pour eux-mêmes d'abord pour la
République ensuite tous les territoires
ultramarins
or s'il est un problème que je connais
qui pourrit la vie du quotidien des
ultramarins c'est celui de la vie chère
donc compatriotes font face à des prix
élevées voire très élevé en tout cas
trop élevé pour se nourrir pour se loger
et se déplacer
cette vicaire s'explique d'abord
par une réalité simple qu'il est
illusoire de nier la géographie
les territoires ultramarins sont marqués
par des handicap structurels liés à
l'isolement l'insularité des reliefs
difficiles et une taille réduite de
marché
il s'agit de lutter contre la vie chère
mais pas de nier qu'il y a des
phénomènes objectifs en effet la
richesse résulte aussi d'autres facteurs
qui ne sont pas eux immuables et qui ne
doivent pas être considérés comme des
fatalités des marchés insuffisamment
ancrés dans leur bassin une concurrence
limitée dans certains secteurs des
filières insuffisamment structurées une
autonomie alimentaire insuffisante et à
renforcer une protection de la
production locale
qui pèse aussi sur les consommateurs
quel fut donc mon premier chantier que
j'ai lancé le jour de mon arrivée au
Dino la première mobilisation massive la
première initiative qui m'a préoccupée
c'est le Oudinot du pouvoir d'achat pour
lutter contre la vie chère
et les résultats sont là
un processus nouveau c'est-à-dire
itératif et non pas simplement une fois
par an en continu avec un bouclier
qualité prix qui prend de l'ampleur en
volume et en produit tout en stabilisant
voire réduisant les prix pour certains
on peut toujours faire plus c'est une
évidence sinon pourquoi ce rêve là
mais je l'entends personne considéré que
le pouvoir que le houdinot du pouvoir
d'achat a été une régression
ma folie zoophile est donc tout progrès
et bonne à prendre toute heureux
économisé pour les plus précaires et bon
à prendre
ainsi la lutte contre la vie chère passe
d'abord par de nombreuses mesures qui
pris isolément peuvent paraître
pointillistes
mais qui ensemble satisfait objectif
celui de soutenir le pouvoir d'achat de
nos compatriotes il faut donc rappeler
les mesures complémentaires qui ont été
décidées par le gouvernement pour faire
face à l'inflation
un plafonnement plus important de la
hausse du montant des loyers dans les
drones par rapport à l'Hexagone une
revalorisation de 5% des subventions
accordées aux collectivités
ultra-marines au titre de la
restauration scolaire
le soutien redressement des compagnies
aériennes en difficulté et on pourrait y
revenir
conditions indispensables
pour que nos compatriotes puissent se
déplacer
il faut d'abord des avions
ne pas appliquer les nouvelles règles de
l'assurance chômage car le marché du
travail en outre-mer diffère évidemment
et malheureusement de celui de
l'Hexagone
rendre opérant le bouclier tarifaire en
outre-mer y compris
pour les grosses collectivités où les
entreprises
grâce au plafonnement des tarifs
réglementés de l'électricité
augmenter la franchise des colis pour
qu'un ultramarin résident dans
l'Hexagone puisse envoyer un cadeau sans
que le destinataire n'a payé ni d'octroi
de mer ni de frais de dédouanement
la méthode pour cela c'est de combiner
tous les moyens possibles de réunir les
parties prenantes pour résoudre
concrètement concrètement une difficulté
et pour trouver à chaque fois
les moyens d'un changement c'est la
méthode du Oudinot du pouvoir d'achat
qui n'est plus celle du bqp simple une
fois par an
cette méthode je viens de à nouveau de
la mettre en oeuvre dans l'aérien après
un dialogue nourrir car il est French be
que je remercie ici ont décidé à
appliquer une réduction commerciale
ciblée sur les bénéficiaires de l'aide à
la continuité territoriale aide que j'ai
d'ailleurs revalorisé
pour les Antilles cela représente une
réduction du prix du billet de 440 euros
quand on y a droit
alors que l'année dernière le soutien
n'était que de 270 euros
au bilan cette méthode mais c'est
peut-être ma conviction mon attitude est
sans doute pas spectaculaire
mais elle obtient des résultats concrets
palpable pas à pas peu à peu sur la
hausse des prix d'ailleurs l'inflation
outre-mer
est inférieure à celle de la métropole
les résultats sont encore plus sensibles
dans le cas des produits alimentaires et
de l'énergie
même si elle s'appuie les plus faibles
que dans l'Hexagone cette inflation
s'applique cependant à des prix plus
élevés en outre-mer
que dans l'Hexagone aussi je ne compte
pas m'arrêter là et souhaite m'attaquer
aux causes structurel de la vie chère
pendant trop longtemps notre logiciel
était centré sur les tailles à dépenses
publiques on voit ce que ça donne
pour compenser les handicaps naturels
pour permettre un rattrapage parfois
pour acheter la paix sociale je pense
que ce n'est pas la bonne méthode cette
logique est à vous le souffle l'horizon
de la jeunesse ne peut pas être le
chômage de l'emploi public ou l'exil et
bien le développement de son territoire
grâce à la valorisation des richesses
endogènes transition énergétique
tourisme économie bleue agriculture
durable commerce régionale lutte contre
le changement climatique protection de
la biodiversité et pour cela
ma philosophie c'est mettre l'accent sur
la création de valeur car seule la
création de valeur permettra d'améliorer
les conditions de vie de nos territoires
d'offrir du pouvoir d'achat d'offrir des
opportunités aux jeunes ultramarins
d'attirer les talents qui contribueront
au développement local et la création de
valeur implique de développer les
circuits courts en soutenant par exemple
l'autonomie alimentaire en renouvelant
les flottes de pêche que pour l'instant
je n'ai pas réussi la création de valeur
nécessite un changement du modèle
économique avec davantage d'agilité pour
les entreprises une adaptation des
formations professionnelles un
accroissement des échanges avec les pays
voisins et une refonte de l'octroi de
mer dont nous parlerons peut-être
de conditions la création de valeur
d'abord disposer de services publics et
d'infrastructures de qualité que ce soit
l'eau en Guadeloupe à Mayotte des ports
capables d'accueillir une nouvelle gamme
de navires dans les Antilles des routes
en Guyane des liaisons aériennes
répondant aux besoins des territoires
quel est l'ambition des différentes
contractualisations en cours et des
sujets de négociation qui sont menés de
manière permanente avec les acteurs dans
ces territoires
seconde condition
disposer d'un logement accessible pour
tous et du foncier aménageable pour les
entreprises
j'aurais l'occasion prochainement de
faire des propositions à la matière mais
pour lutter contre la vie chère pour
soutenir la création de valeur j'ai
besoin d'identification précise des
problèmes d'où mon avis favorable sur la
création de cette commission
pour susciter une coalition d'acteurs
permettant de relever ses défis car par
définition
l'État ne crée pas il pose le cadre et
il essaye d'accompagner
cela nécessite de mobiliser les pouvoirs
publics locaux mais ne mobiliser aussi
le secteur privé et de ne pas décourager
l'entrepreneuriat
je souhaite donc que vos travaux
contribuent à mieux classer les facteurs
de la vie chère spécifique aux outre-mer
sans tabou à questionner les faits des
politiques publiques conduits de
nombreuses années en la matière
mais aussi parce que nul n'a
la capacité de dire qu'il possède la
vérité seule de proposer des changements
contribuent à soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat
à diminuer tendentiellement les prix de
vente aux particuliers à soutenir le
développement économique
cela me permettra au Conseil d'audition
d'essayer partiellement à tout moins à
tout le moins de rendre compte de
l'action du Gouvernement sur ce sujet
depuis près d'un an je vous remercie
monsieur le président
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
je vais passer la parole notre
rapporteur mais j'utilise toujours
privilège présidentielle pour lui lui
chiper la vedette en début de réunion et
vous vous dites qu'il faut de parler
sans tabou donc je vais poser des
questions qui souvent sont
de façon un peu discrète
on donne à la croix de mer beaucoup de
beaucoup de l'octroi de mer beaucoup de
fonctions pensez-vous qu'il y a un rôle
dans le prochain servicement des prix et
selon votre réponse pensez-vous qu'il
soit nécessaire de le modifier puisque
c'est quand même un des serpents de mer
qui qui rôde encore de savoir s'il faut
ou non
modifier notre mère ma deuxième question
sera sur la sur rémunération
des fonctionnaires dont d'aucun disent
que c'est aussi une force de classe
moyenne un peu artificielle qui existe
sur le territoire et qui fait que qui
peut conquérir à la pompe peut concourir
à la aux effets est-ce que c'est votre
avis est-ce que vous avez des éléments
par rapport à cela et qu'en pensez-vous
avec un petit agenda c'est n'hésite pas
dans ce cas une difficulté sur la
retraite de ces fonctionnaires qui lors
de la retraite ne bénéficient plus de
cette rémunération sur rémunération et
qui du coup se retrouve dans une
situation fragilisée en matière de de
revenus et peut-être une dernière
question c'est pensez-vous que l'état
non
de votre de votre fait ni du fait de ce
gouvernement mais en tout cas t'en parle
le passé n'a pas n'a-t-il pas un peu
trop appuyé sur pressurer les finances
des collectivités locales lors de
quand on était sous le règne de la RGPP
par exemple il y a bien longtemps mais
enfin quand même avec des conséquences
qui a privé celle-ci de capacité ou pas
quel est votre avis par rapport à ça le
rapport patiente en la matière attends
sa pensée qu'il y a quand même eu de
trop forte promption sur des
collectivités qui étaient déjà un
fragilisées de en charge une population
qui elle-même fragilisée pensez-vous
là-dessus que la réaction de l'État en
matière d'aide au travers des contrats
Corum est à la mesure du problème
oui je suis favorable à une réforme de
l'octroi de mer
et en accord avec monsieur le ministre
de l'Économie des Finances et monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer je le proposerai comme
orientation au prochain somme
mais attention à ce qu'on dit nos droits
de mer c'est d'abord la première
ressource des collectivités locales et
ça marche bien
l'inflation en ce sens a permis qui
rétablissement des comptes des
collectivités locales grâce à l'octroi
de mer
mission remplie sur le fait je fournis
les crédits aux collectivités locales
deuxième regard
c'est d'une complexité diabolique
il y a plus de 20 000 articles donc 10
sur les eaux gazeuses personne n'y
comprend rien
troisième sujet
on ne touchera pas l'octroi de mer sans
l'accord des présidents de collectivités
ça ne marchera pas et donc le boulot
c'est de trouver un système qui est
l'accord global qui est d'accord global
qu'est-ce qu'on cherche les financements
des collectivités
la protection
des entreprises de production installées
mais pas de celle qui ne sont pas
installés
éventuellement la protection écologique
tout en gardant un pouvoir de décision
collectivités locales donc ma
proposition mais ce n'est que la mienne
mais les publics
c'est
de d'avoir une réforme globale de la
fiscalité qui comprend plusieurs sujets
d'abord une réflexion sur la
défiscalisation
le défiscalisation servent l'objectif de
création de valeur et pas le confort
deuxième idée
donner aux collectivités concernées
région ou départements ça dépend des
secteurs la capacité de fixer très
librement les assises sur l'alcool et le
tabac
pour financer des surcroîtes dépenses
sanitaires qu'imposent le vieillissement
de la population
troisième idée réfléchir à l'évolution
de la consommation des carburants et
donc inventer une taxation de l'énergie
électrique pour les véhicules enfin
quatrième idée faire un mixte d'une TVA
sur un autre nom d'une taxe à la
consommation locale peut-être
fixé encadré mais dans les taux seraient
fixés avec des degrés de liberté par les
collectivités elles-mêmes
alors ça pose pas de problème mais
récupérer d'une seule manière par les
services Cisco il y a deux endroits où
il y a pas de TVA donc ça sera un peu
plus long
mais pour ce qui est les territoires il
y a déjà de la TVA ça sera un complément
fixé localement et à côté une taxe
octroi de mer réformée
fixé par les collectivités locales
ayant pour but de protéger
les entreprises réellement productives
sur le territoire de chacun de ces
territoires
c'est l'intuition que j'en ai ça sera
compliqué difficile mais j'affirme que
rien ne pourra se faire si ça menace les
finances des collectivités locales
et rien ne pourra se faire si ce n'est
pas d'accord partie avec l'ensemble des
exécutifs qui ont en charge cela parce
que les questions je réponds après au
reste comme vous voulez monsieur le
président
moi je continue
deuxième sujet la surémération des
fonctionnaires
ma réponse est non j'ai pas envie d'y
toucher je suis pas là pour diminuer
pour proposer diminuer le traitement
d'un certain nombre de salariés de
l'État
ne bouge pas
troisième question
les retraites oui on est reparti grâce à
un certain nombre d'entre vous de
parlementaires qui m'ont saisi qui ont
saisi
on est reparti pour revisiter ce qui
avait été décidé il y a quelques années
la baisse tendance
qui était prévue le 19 juin était
reporté début juillet je crois mais on a
des propositions à faire et je pense que
on va arriver à faire des choses
constructives enfin le quorum
c'est-à-dire l'aide de collectivités
locales
ça marche
ça marche sur le Corum
c'est d'abord une aide financière qui
était de 10 millions que les
collectivités locales il n'y a pas
le dont jusqu'à la fin 2023
l'assemblée a bien voulu accorder 30
millions de plus sur les corums sur le
budget 2023 donc il est vrai 20% réservé
aux seméac c'était une nouveauté pour
assurer le financement de l'eau en
Guadeloupe
et 10 millions pour d'autres
collectivités il y avait 31 communes
éligibles il y en a 20 je crois à peu
près 20 qui ont fait une demande et donc
et toutes les communes qui ont bénéficié
d'un Corum sont contents et leur
financement se redressent c'est un
effort partagé collectif et à la fois
peu d'argent de l'assistance de
l'assistance technique aux communes et
j'ai malheureusement plus de candidats
de ce que je ne pourrais en décider
contenu
des 10 millions de plus qui s'ajoutent
aux 10 millions
du précédent plan Corum sans compter
donc les 20 millions de smerg voilà ma
réponse une satisfaction une
satisfaction des collectivités
bénéficiaires du corps mais c'est un
effort pour elle mais c'est un effort
partagé je les en remercie
et bien que ça soit un effort il y a
plus de candidats ça prouve que ça
marche et la situation financière des
sociétés des entreprises
pardon les collectivités qui adhèrent à
ce process s'améliore et c'est bien
je pense que vous mesurez monsieur le
ministre que le fait qu'une file
d'attente risque d'inspirer des
parlementaires dans le débat budgétaire
qui viendra mais enfin j'espère c'est
pas mais ce n'est pas moi qui vote
absolument monsieur rapporteur
merci bonjour à toutes et à tous
monsieur le ministre
quel est votre analyse aujourd'hui sur
la concentration horizontale et
verticale et donc la situation des
oligopoles et des monopoles sur nos
territoires
comment expliquer vous qu'en 2023 les
outils de l'État comme l'observatoire
des prix des marges et des revenus ou
bien le délégué interministériel n'est
aucun moyen mais aucun moyen ni pour
identifier ni pour contrôler ni les
marges ni les revenus des gangs
d'autre part les grands groupes ne
déposent pas leurs comptes malgré
l'obligation légale
de droit de les déposer pourquoi l'État
n'intervient pas pour qu'il y ait de la
transparence
quatrièmement sous la continuité
territoriale les prix ont augmenté de
plus de 40 à 50%
, ce que vous proposez est très
largement insuffisant
parce que à une augmentation
conjonctuelle de l'inflation s'ajoute
des problématiques d'autres structurées
quelles sont les mesures concrètes
en dehors
de ces aides
ponctuels que vous donnez pouvez-vous
mettre en place notamment pour rétablir
l'équité parce que la cause tant mieux
pour elle possède près 290 millions à
200 millions d'euros de continuité
territoriale alors que les outre-mer
c'est à dire les 10 territoires
concernés à eux seuls 45 millions quand
comptez-vous
équilibrer en tout cas donner de
l'équité de traitement ne serait-ce que
pour ces moyens de continuité
territoriale merci
sur les oligopoles
ou les monopoles mais un peu
quasi monopole sur certains territoires
du transport maritime
sinon en général c'est des oligopoles
des duos
le premier sujet
c'est que et c'est mon histoire
personnelle aussi
c'est qu'il appartient à chacun par la
création d'emplois la création de
société de lutter contre les monopoles
c'est clair le monopole c'est parce
qu'il y a personne qui fait rien contre
d'où l'idée de création de valeur et des
délaisses entreprises j'y reviendrai
tout à l'heure si l'occasion m'en est
donnée
à chaque duopole à chaque monopole il y
a une face dual
la face dual c'est que le service est
fait certes parfois cher
mais sinon il est pas fait mais sinon il
est pas fait
je regrette mais c'est peut-être la
politique de l'État depuis des années
qu'on aide pas assez des créateurs
d'entreprise qu'on est de passer la
création de valeur si je dis que mon
ADN outre-mer c'est de la création de
valeur parce que je pense que c'est le
meilleur moyen
de lutter contre les monopoles
monopole ayant sa face dual
c'est que ça fait quelque chose sinon il
y a des cas où il se fait rien rien
et ça c'est mon drame
je milite en ce moment pour la création
d'une société d'investissement outre-mer
large ouverte pour tous ceux qui ont un
vrai projet outre-mer j'espère bien
réussir c'est le meilleur moyen de
lutter contre les monopoles c'est le
meilleur moyen c'est qu'il y ait des
concurrents
et je dois dire que lorsque sur
l'affaire remarket
j'étais très favorable à l'avenue d'un
concurrent venu d'ailleurs
tous n'y étaient pas favorables
y compris ceux qui disent lutter contre
les monopoles on a mis quelqu'un venu
d'ailleurs ça met un peu d'air c'est
bien c'est bien mais il nous faut
constater
on a un sujet de transport on y
reviendra transport maritime
mais qui existe d'ailleurs qui vient des
servir qui vient des servir ces
territoires on est ouvert à tous on est
ouvert à tous
tous les transporteurs sont les
bienvenus
mais d'aller desservir
une île de 6000 habitants
il y a pas beaucoup de candidats il y a
pas beaucoup de candidats d'aller voilà
c'est ça le sujet et donc il nous faut
travailler avec ceux qui ont un large
monopole on va dire parce que c'est pas
total c'est pas tout à fait exact un
large monopole pour améliorer les prix
pour améliorer la desserte pour
améliorer la cadence et pour que le
service soit meilleur c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire mais lutter contre le
monopole du transport maritime vous
faites allusion à cela
quand ça s'est pris
j'ai
concurrent à ceux qui sont là qui me
disent mais quand un coup arrête de
faire baisser les prix on va mourir
arrête de faire baisser les prix on va
mourir
donc c'est pas aussi simple que ça mais
si vous avez des transporteurs qui
veulent venir tous les toutes les
semaines pour faire la desserte
j'applaudis dès demain moi je n'en
trouve pas
l'ensemble des questions que j'ai vu et
on va parler de la grande distribution
aussi bien sûr c'est le deuxième sujet
c'est le deuxième sujet des monopoles
oligopoles
mon action par exemple c'était de faire
venir un Mauricien à la Réunion et
encore une fois ils étaient pas tous
contents
y compris ceux qui disent halte monopole
et donc il nous faut à chaque fois
essayer
de faire venir des gens supplémentaires
et lutter contre les abus de monopole
j'ajoute que sur la grande distribution
c'est pas un monopole ils sont trois ou
quatre partout ils sont au moins trois
ou quatre il y a pas de monopole du
groupe Bernard Riotte ce n'est pas vrai
et ils se font une concurrence entre les
deux entre les trois entre les quatre
mais
donc je ne crois pas dans la grande
distribution je crois sur un certain
nombre de sujets que le monopole est
plus difficile mais sur la distribution
la grande distribution
je suis pas sûr que
il est pas
il y a la concurrence sur suffisante
dans la grande distribution mais je
prends l'exemple des autres Mayotte on
va d'ailleurs bloquer le prix de l'eau
réglementairement
réglementairement on va essayer de
bloquer le prix de l'eau
mais quand d'accord partie j'ai obtenu
un blocage du prix de l'eau zéro marge
zéro marge à Mayotte sur l'eau quel est
le problème c'est que tous les lolos
achètent de l'eau au prix sans marge et
le revendre avec une grosse marge
c'est ça le prix de l'eau à Mayotte le
prix de en bouteille et donc de temps en
temps les sur la grande distribution il
y a des oligopoles je ne crois pas qu'il
y ait de monopole sur grande
distribution alimentaire alimentaire
j'ajoute que d'avoir trois ou quatre
partenaires
présents me permet d'avoir un bqp plus
tout à fait nouveau
le nombre de produits a augmenté les
prix ont baissé les prix ont baissé dans
le panier dans le panier de la
consommation si c'était l'argile c'était
bloqué ou sa baisse et l'inflation
monsieur le rapporteur l'inflation est
plus faible outre-mer qu'en France
hexagonale
c'est une réalité elle s'applique mais
si elle s'applique à un niveau de prix
qui était supérieur elle est beau un
sens l'inflation y est plus faible le
prix de l'essence y est plus faible ça
s'applique à une population différente
mais il n'y a pas d'inflation supérieure
en outre-mer puisqu'elle est dans la
France hexagonale en tout cas le système
décupait plus notamment le permet et
c'est pour moi une évidence qui veut pas
dire qu'il faille pas continuer à
travailler parce qu'on s'appuie on
travaille pour une population dans le
niveau de vie est inférieur on travaille
pour une population dont les revenus
sont inférieurs
cesse de côté de logement c'est un sujet
mais sur la grande distribution
alimentaire
le taux d'inflation n'est pas supérieur
il est inférieur
outre-mer quand métropole il s'applique
à une pommée voilà
je vous enverrai les chiffres précis
mais après reste les moyens de lutter
contre ça et vous avez et je le dis très
simplement j'ai pris rendez-vous avec la
nouvelle directrice je trouve que
l'action
de la DGCCRF outre-mer est insuffisante
que sa présence est insuffisante
c'est à eux je m'adresse c'est eux les
correspondants naturels de l'Autorité de
la concurrence qui n'a pas tous les
pouvoirs
que on veut bien lui prêter il y a des
règles il y a des lois
et je vois assez souvent
monsieur Benoît Quéré
pour travailler ensemble pour déterminer
quand est-ce qu'il doit agir je lui mets
des sujets il donne des sujets
mais ma grande
insatisfaction par exemple
insatisfaction c'est la présence de la
DGCCRF outre-mer je compte beaucoup sur
la nouvelle direction qui a été nommée
avec un jour trois semaines donc je la
vois la semaine prochaine
en tout cas dans les dans les 10 jours
qui viennent parce que ça c'est pas bien
ça c'est pas bien il me semble
vous m'interrogez ensuite sur
la
continuité territoriale
et l'idée qui aurait
250 euros par personne contre 17 peu
importe peu importe je pense que cette
analyse
257 euros par an et par habitant pour
les habitants de la Corse et 16 euros
par an pour les ultramars je conteste ce
chiffre des ultravins
si vous additionnez
toute la défiscalisation des avions tous
les avions sont défiscalisés mais c'est
vous qui autorisez cette
désistérialisation par les crédits que
vous donnez
c'est des dizaines de millions d'euros
chaque année chaque année
un avion c'est 30 millions d'euros de
défis à peu près comme ils en achètent
tout en permanence et on les donne sans
état d'âme dès lors que la compagnie
alors additionnant
les défis
additionnant les abandons de créances
dont je rappelle que sur Air Austral
c'est 130 millions
que sur Corsair il y a deux ans c'est
100 millions qu'on m'en demande 140
plus le prix de la défiscalisation des
avions
plus
tout ce que font les OPCO pour envoyer
les gens ici se former en métropole plus
les congés bonifiés plus tout ce que
paye la sécurité sociale en transport
j'ai pas fait le chiffre mais j'ai
demandé à mes services ils sont un peu
retard mais à mon avis
on sera pas très loin par contre ça ne
suffit pas
ça ne suffit pas
ce que nous essayons de faire je le dis
c'est en deux ans de doubler
en 23 24 25 de doubler la capacité
d'intervention de la DOM
et de double et de changer d'ailleurs un
petit peu son orientation ça je pense y
arriver grâce à la négociations que j'ai
demandé au directeur de la Dom de faire
avec les compagnies aériennes pas normal
quand une instance 70 000 billets on
n'est pas 10 balles de réduction
ça doit changer
en optimisant sa gestion et en finance
en pas des choses qui sont financées par
ailleurs je pense à la formation
professionnelle c'est pas la Dom de
financer de la formation professionnelle
en allant chercher du FSE en allant
chercher des crédits budgétaires que
j'ai demandé dès 2024
supplémentaires par rapport à ce qui m'a
déjà été accordée en 2023 pour 2024 pour
la Dom j'espère doubler le budget
d'intervention de la Dom mais je vous
dois monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur mais je le diffuserai à tous
les membres de la commission
ce que je crois être parce que on en
oublie peut-être qu'il faut pas les
compter comme si comme ça c'est la
vérité elle est pas binaire
le coût par habitant
le coup parle bénéficiaire je l'aide au
transport aérien
je fais environ 3 avions pas par an
ça doit être ça ça fait déjà 100
millions
ça n'existe pas pour la Corse
hein
c'est 100 millions chaque année
les prix restent élevés c'est pas mais
je dis pas que les prix sont bas c'est
pas ça que je veux dire je dis que le
chiffre de 17 euros est inexact
mais les prix sont trop élevés d'où
l'idée
d'augmenter largement le budget de la
Dom de travailler avec les compagnies
pour leur dire faites un effort ce café
et dans l'ensemble de ces dépenses de
transport je souhaite que vous n'oubliez
pas toutes les petits chiffres qui sont
la desserts de Miquelon la discerne de
foutouna
ce qu'on donne à erguyan toute la
continuité territoriale secondaire qui
pour les citoyens de ces territoires
sont tout à fait importants
j'essaie de faire obtenir dans mon dans
le budget 2024 l'argent nécessaire
j'étais
ce matin avec Clément bonne et à 13h
avec
CBC pour avoir l'argent qui devrait
continuer à avancer sur ces sujets
j'ai pas dû répondre à la question
de l'eau des eaux PMR et des moyens des
epmr
depuis 2019
je suis pour rien
ça a été doublé l'aide
et passer pour atteindre 600.000 euros
de fonctionnement je ne suis pas
pour salarié les gens de l'Opéra
et à la fois un côté professionnel pour
ceux qui sont au nom des services
publics et un côté militant pour ceux
qui représentent les consommateurs
pas d'avis de si j'avais
de l'argent pour les payer je les
mettrai pour faire baisser les prix des
transports aériens
vous m'avez parlé peut-être aussi non du
délégué à la concurrence excusez-moi
je regrette
que le délégué à la concurrence
ne soit pas directement rattachée au
ministère de l'Outre-mer ça va être un
de mes combats
perdu là-bas
ça le fait pas
la preuve donc ma demande auprès du
ministre de l'Économie des Finances
c'est qu'il soit rattachée au ministère
de l'Outre-mer
et qui viennent m'aider et qui viennent
m'aider
à cette politique de diversification de
l'offre et donc d'une pression
supplémentaire sur les prix
je suis non satisfait du positionnement
du délégué interministériel
à la vie chère ça marche pas donc il
faut changer la proposition c'est de
ramener au plus vite dans le giron dans
le giron du ministère de l'Outre-mer
et pour l'instant
je suis pas très satisfait de comment ça
se passe
personne s'en occupe là-bas
j'ai pas le souci premier des cabinets à
Bercy
c'est pas logique
j'aimerais qu'il soit rattaché à
quelqu'un dont c'est le souci premier je
pense pouvoir réussir
sur l'inflation vous aviez l'air
dubitatif
en Martinique au total au total sur
l'année 2022
4,2% en métropole 5,9
ça c'est
sur l'alimentaire en Martinique 5,5 en
métropole 12,7 en énergie en Martinique
ça a été capé 15% en métropole 23,1 ça
s'applique à des personnes différentes
oui et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
continuer à se battre
mais je crois qu'il faut reconnaître
qu'il n'y a pas d'inflation
exponentielle dans les outre-mer par
rapport à la France hexagonale
j'aurais beaucoup pas dire mais juste un
point
comparer les inflations sous des bases
différentes ça n'a pas de sens quand il
y a zéro structurellement
de problématiques en France hexagonale
il y a 40% au départ de Vichères dans
nos territoires did outre-mer donc on
est déjà 40% au départ et après vous
rajoutez les 4,2% et les 52 donc on
n'est pas sous les mêmes références
monsieur le ministre on peut pas
comparer des éléments qui ne sont pas
sous le même pied d'égalité donc sous
les mêmes critères
vous voulez que j'étais d'accord avec
vous
ce contre quoi je me lève c'est le fait
de dire que l'inflation est supérieur
non
l'inflation c'est le mouvement des prix
et grâce à l'effort de tous vous même et
le rapport va nous aider
l'inflation y est inférieure mais elle
s'applique à un niveau de prix au départ
supérieur je ne le conteste pas
et elle s'applique à une population
qui a des difficultés de pouvoir d'achat
mais l'inflation n'y est pas supérieure
notamment parce que nous faisons les
efforts que nous faisons sinon je ne
doute pas que ça s'envolerait encore
plus bien je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre alors vous allez avoir une
première salle de question donc je vais
donner l'ordre simplement avec en fait
je trouve tout à fait légitime que
d'aucun est aussi envie de s'exprimer
pas une composer une question quand on
administre de d'outreurs devant soi
c'est normal qu'on est là dessus je
l'invite juste une sorte de modération
au niveau du temps pour qu'on puisse
tous le faire de bonnes conditions alors
dans l'ordre monsieur Perceval gaillard
avait été le premier à la main suivi par
au sud David Riemann il me suffit de
tailler Monsieur Jean et Monsieur
judo
et Madame Bassir donc voilà on va
comment peut-être que je le
fractionnerais en deux en fonction de la
taille pour qu'on puisse
un peu plus de dynamique dans les dans
les réponse allez-y merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues bon la question de la vie
chère en outre-mer elle est structurelle
et à les conditionner par deux
principales
facteurs de principaux facteurs c'est la
formation des prix on en parle beaucoup
dans le cadre de cette commission et
c'est celle des revenus prestations
sociales est revenue dont on parle un
peu moins vous l'avez vous-même reconnu
lors de l'audition de la commission des
finances et aujourd'hui même en disant
que pour vous l'inflation était
inférieure dans nos territoires par
rapport à l'Hexagone mais qu'elle
touchait finalement une population et
qu'elle était subie par une population
ayant des revenus je cite nettement
inférieurs à ceux de l'Hexagone bon donc
je vais avoir une salle de question
concernant les revenus la première
question vous avez commencé à y répondre
mais peut-être vous allez pouvoir donner
plus d'éléments c'est le dossier de la
surémulation donc va-t-il être abordé
lors du somme de lundi et si oui dans
quel dans quelle direction deuxième
question la question des revenus
touchent également évidemment c'est ceux
qui ne sont pas dans la fonction
publique ou assimiler il perçoivent des
salaires ou des allocations basées sur
le coût de la vie dans l'Hexagone donc
avez-vous étudi une hypothèse d'indexer
les prestations sociales et le SMIC sur
le coût de la vie outre-mer c'est à dire
de les fixer par rapport au niveau de
vie dans chaque territoire d'outre-mer
troisième question vous avez évoqué
lundi devant la commission des finances
la création de 6400 emplois à la Réunion
alors nous on aimerait savoir sous quel
contrat avec quel rémunération dans quel
secteur en gros c'est 6400 emplois à la
Réunion créé ces quatre emplois et où
quatrième question vous avez-vous une
évaluation de l'impact des exonérations
de cotisations et non de charges comme à
chaque fois c'est dit sur la création
d'emplois et sur les possibilités du
coup d'augmentation des salaires de
cinquième question vous avez également
parlé d'une étude que vous avez demandé
sur l'octroît de mer on a compris que ça
allait être au sujet du somme donc cette
étude confront-elle un volet impacte sur
les prix ou c'est uniquement un point
sur la réforme de manière globale de la
fiscalité de manière globale et enfin
dernière question à quête date
pourrait-on avoir le dispositif cadre à
venir pour la Réunion voilà je vous
remercie on fera en deux salles
David
merci président
monsieur le ministre donc moi les
questions sont posées après moi c'est
quelques remarques par rapport aux
interventions qui moi qui m'interpelle
qui me pose question
l'analyse que vous faites sur la 60e sur
le territoire elle est quelques Péronnes
en ce qui me concerne pourquoi vous
partez du postulat que nos situations
font que en Sark Booth nous nos
territoires à être accrochés aux données
de l'état pour pour faire continuer les
choses c'est comme ça que je traduis
votre marque de départ parce que
justement on n'est pas sur la création
de valeur
si si vous l'avez dit vous pourrez
écouter votre c'est comme ça que nous
nous le comprenons j'aimerais juste
rappeler quand même que historiquement
il y a avant départementalisation 46
après départementalisation avant
départementalisation la plupart des
territoires dit d'outre-mer avec la
capacité à exporter ils avaient une
balance une balance économique positive
ils exportaient leur marchandises sur
plusieurs filières après la
départementalisation qui était gaz de
égalité traitement pour tous les
Français que ça leur le d'habitation ce
qui est resté totalement faux puisque je
rappelle que les minimasu se sont
arrivés à peu près au même niveau de
l'Hexagone des années 80 donc il a fallu
40 ans
derrière ça lorsque nous regardons
chaque territoire sur la configuration
économique d'accord on voit que c'est le
même dispositif qui appliqué de la même
manière donc lorsque vous dites
[Musique]
il y a des grandes femmes historiques
qui bénéficient d'un certain large de la
part de l'État ça sont de mes propos oui
c'est confirmé c'est vu c'est structurel
on voit que la chose est faite pour que
80% minima de nos produits viennent de
l'Europe pour ne pas dire de la France
hexagonale donc ça bénéficie à des
familles bien précises derrière ça
lorsque on regarde les produits qui
quittent l'Hexagone parvenir sur nos
territoires je rappelle que lorsque ça
part d'un port français de l'Hexagone
pour arriver à un port français dit
d'outre-mer c'est considéré comme de
l'exportation d'accord donc ça va ça va
dans des sur les pays étrangers
c'est-à-dire que la taxation est
différente déjà donc on est plus sur un
territoire français à ce moment-là
puisque nous sommes considérés à
l'export de faire des billets étrangers
donc là aussi moi j'ai posé des
questions au niveau du ministère
d'économie du budget pourquoi est-ce que
lorsque les marchandises quittent les
ports français ils arrivent sur des
portes français ils sont considérés
comme de l'exportation on m'a dit oui
c'est par rapport à l'attention l'octroi
de merde
donc vous parlez tout à l'heure de
réviser la primeur de pas le faire
disparaître forcément on entend bien
qu'il y a une volonté de réviser bon
certains disent que c'est un serpent de
mer c'est pas d'aujourd'hui ça sera
peut-être pour demain on en sait rien du
tout sauf que le financement des
collectivités aujourd'hui sur la table
vous avez répondu en partie mais
nécessairement c'est que je rappelle que
le droit de mère pourquoi le droit de
mère a été créé au départ l'autre mère
était créé au départ c'était pour
protéger les productions locales par
rapport aux importations de même produit
l'octroi n'a pas été au départ instaurer
pour financer la collectivité locale
maintenant faut bien faut bien remettre
les choses dans leur contexte ensuite
sur la quantité territoriale vous avez
expliqué vous avez un certain nombre de
chiffres qui permettent aujourd'hui de
dire que l'État est pas mal les
territoires mais lorsque vous faites je
rappelle la défiscalisation quand elle
est faite elle va pas dans sur les
comptes des collectivités encore moins
de population concernées elle va dans
les contes des entreprises qui font
l'achat de ces produits là avion bateau
tout ce qu'on veut qu'on se focaliser ça
bénéficie à l'investisseur d'accord pas
forcément au territoire pourquoi parce
que derrière vous voulez économique et
social il y a un débat qui est qui qui
m'a Story c'est de dire est-ce que
vraiment la défiscalisation permet la
création de valeur parce que tout à
l'heure vous n'en avez parlé on voit que
il y a pas forcément plus de création
d'emploi que ça il n'y a pas plus de
développement des entreprises que ça
donc là dessus c'est un vrai sujet aussi
au niveau de la défisc on est pour mais
il faut sortir du gagnant-gagnant tant
pour celui qui investit tant pour les
territoires et la population qui a que
cet investissement là ensuite pour ne
pas être trop long
vous avez parlé aussi
[Musique]
de la partie
oui l'inflation pour finir mais je
rappelle que l'inflation globalement
c'est la montée globale de tous les prix
qui infinie font que la monnaie perde la
valeur d'accord mais pourquoi il y a une
différence comme ça dans l'inflation
entre les territoires hexagonales et nos
territoires d'illoutre-mer je rappelle
que sur le territoire il y a pas mal de
prix qui sont encore administrés je
prends le prix du carburant parce qu'il
est plafonné je prends encore
comme exemple
lorsque
au niveau au niveau de l'énergie
l'électricité
il a concurrence est à la production
mais pas sur la consommation ce qui
n'est pas le cas dans les agones il y a
plusieurs points comme ça lorsque vous
faites les comparaisons qui sont
différents de l'Hexagone la concurrence
en matière d'électricité sur l'énergie
elle est totale sur l'hexagone sur nos
territoires la concurrence est à la
production d'électricité mais sur le
transport et la distribution il n'y a
pas de concurrence ça veut dire que nous
aujourd'hui en Guyane c'est par exemple
dans les territoires d'hydromère il y a
c'est le tarif bleu
donc c'est les prix perigway il n'y a
pas de concurrence à ce niveau là donc
c'est pour ça que en l'occurrence sur
l'énergie l'inflation est totalement
différente et c'est pour ça que vous
avez une différence déflation et ça veut
dire quoi c'est que lorsque le public
mais la main sur les choses essentielles
les vitales sur certains territoires on
voit que les l'inflation n'est pas aussi
forte que je dois l'Hexagone là où c'est
totalement libéralisé et la vraie
question infinie parce qu'on parle de la
vie chère
l'état dit ouais on en fait tant on a
mis temps de route tondeuse sur pour les
territoires d'outre-mer mais la vraie
question monsieur le ministre c'est
aujourd'hui par rapport à nos réalités
puisque chaque a rappelé les chiffres de
pauvreté qu'on a sur les différents
territoires
le défaut de structuration initiale qui
soit le territoire et ça c'est bien
l'état qu'il a mis la mise en place
c'est quelle est la volonté réelle de
l'État pourquoi parce que vous aimez
remarqué et vous l'avez dit vous-même
dans une condition que vous n'avez pas
la main sur les prix qui s'amplifier
puisqu'on est sur le marché les bons
mais par contre c'est pas celui-là il
faut que l'État ait une réponse pour les
territoires concernés quand vous dites
que on verra pas venir transport er pour
6000 6000 personnes je dis oui ok mais
que fallait pas en réponse à cela est-ce
que l'État ne peut pas se substituer au
transport en privé qui ne veulent pas
venir parce qu'ils n'aurait pas de
marche garantie sur ça pour finir et
vous le savez très bien en tant qu'on se
présente la creux beaucoup d'entreprises
viennent produire sur le territoire
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont des prix de
rachat garantie une somme d'accord ou
pas
non mais justement s'ils viennent chez
nous c'est bien parce que aussi ils ont
des prix de rachats garanti vers la
creux nous sommes d'accord ça veut dire
que lorsque l'état meurt pas de
dispositif qui garantit deux choses pour
ces investisseurs ils viennent et ils
développent certains nombre de choses il
crée de l'emploi donc ça veut bien dire
que la réponse qui est posée poisson
dans la vie cherche nos territoires
elles doivent venir de l'État parce que
c'est structurel et pas conjoncturé
cette histoire là je vous remercie bien
c'est le ministre je vais vous laisser
répondre parce que ces deux
interventions bien denses genre
j'annonce tout de suite que les deux
salves supplémentaires seront Mr pardon
qui seront bien sûr très denses aussi je
n'en doute pas c'est pour ça que je
préfère refaire que deux à la fois
ensuite monsieur judo et Madame Bassir
et je sens que Monsieur voudra
poser une question j'anticipe c'est ça
je comprends bien je comprends bien
allez-y je vous en prie
en français hexagonale il y a un
monopole du transport et de la
distribution sur l'électricité
il y a pas de monopole sur la revanche
c'est important
il y a un monopole transport
distribution
comment
c'est ça non mais vous avez dit
transport distribution donc j'essaie
j'essaie d'être j'essaye d'être exacte
tellement de questions c'est compliqué
sur les pourquoi c'est pourquoi on a
importation exportation pas c'est un
régime de TVA différent et de mer
c'est pas le même système de taxes à la
consommation octobre plus TVA notre
d'ailleurs que
l'effort sur la baisse des prix c'est
qu'il y a pas de TVA
à Mayotte et en Guyane
c'est un effort considérable pour faire
baisser les prix de manière administrée
c'est de dire là-dessus
il y a pas de TVA on prend pas et ça me
paraît tout à fait normal contenu du
niveau de vie du niveau de revenu mais
c'est un effort sur les prix
je crois vraiment que la défiscalisation
toute chose est partagée entre
l'entrepreneur et le consommateur et son
client la défiscalisation c'est vrai
participent
à l'augmentation de la valeur de
l'entreprise si j'ose dire c'est un
effort de l'État sur la valeur de
l'entreprise mais c'est ce qui permet
aussi
d'avoir la rentabilité recherchée sans
augmenter les prix c'est partager vous
savez toutes choses et partager
l'économie c'est bien les salariés
des entrepreneurs et des clients
et vous tournez à 3 et pour ça qu'il y a
des négociations sociales c'est pour ça
qu'il y a des conflits sociaux c'est
pour ça que l'État intervient aussi de
temps en temps pour empêcher que les
primes tout le monde se mette d'accord
pour les petits primo donc la
défiscalisation oui ça permet de créer
de la valeur Oui ça permet de créer de
l'emploi oui ça permet de faire des
bénéfices aux entreprises mais ça permet
aussi de faire baisser les prix toutes
choses égales par ailleurs en tout cas
qui n'augmente pas toutes choses égales
par ailleurs sur l'exportation
c'était clair sur le sur le
[Musique]
l'indexation inflationniste
je comprends pas tout à fait la question
l'indexation tout indexation est
inflationniste
on a un vrai sujet
d'indexation d'un certain nombre de
paramètres sur les petits revenus sur
lesquels on essaye de travailler vous
connaissez le sujet de Mayotte aussi
bien que moi mais mais ça vaut aussi sur
un certain nombre de prestations qui ne
sont pas
à la hauteur
de ce qu'elle pourrait être de ce
qu'elle devrait être et il faut donc
continuer à les faire avancer les unes
après les autres les unes après les
autres
le lien entre la métropole
au niveau de l'exportation de
l'importation du commerce bi-nivoque
c'est évidemment le résultat d'un modèle
économique que vous et moi sommes
d'accord pour changer
mais ça se change pas comme ça il nous
faut trouver des entrepreneurs il nous
faut trouver des marchés est-ce que
c'est normal
que 80% du poisson consommé à la
Guadeloupe soit du poisson à porter
pas terrible
mais ça se change pas comme ça il nous
faut travailler sur la flotte et on
revient sur un sujet que personne n'a
aborder encore sur l'importance des
réglementations européennes
sur le poids des normes dans les prix le
poids des normes dans les prix qu'il
faut combattre avancer doucement
mais le sujet ruparup est un vrai sujet
est un vrai sujet chaque chose à sa
phase binaire vous savez et sur la
création de valeur je vais le député
Ryman
oui la Guadeloupe
pourrait être extrêmement riche
extrêmement riche si elle exploiter son
pétrole
c'est bois
sonore son poisson
je suis pas sûr qu'on y arrive comme ça
même avec une Guadeloupe totalement
autonome
comment
la Guyane qu'est-ce que j'ai dit
la Guyane il y a pas d'Oran il y a pas
d'or en Guadeloupe
c'est le jetlag comme vous dites tout ça
est une affaire d'équilibre et de
progrès ce que je peux dire très
officiellement
c'est qu'il me semble il me semble
mais parlementaires sont là pour
critiquer pour proposer et pour aller
plus loin
que la politique
qui suivit par ce gouvernement essaye de
favoriser la création de richesse locale
essaie de favoriser
les bas niveau de revenus essaie de
favoriser la concurrence est-ce que ça
va assez vite certainement pas est-ce
que les contraintes sont fortes c'est
pas qu'elles sont fortes c'est qu'elles
sont énormes énormes énormes et puis il
nous faut des producteurs il nous faut
des gens qui ont envie de travailler
je percevrai le gaillard la surémération
moi
je la proposerai pas je l'ai dit en
suppression pour les fonctionnaires mais
si vous la proposez la fin de la
surémération pour tous les
fonctionnaires ça sera un scoop je ne
crois pas
je ne le crois pas vous proposez de
mettre tout le monde a un surémération
je suis pas sûr que ça soit très
anti-inflationniste après il faut
trouver oui il faut augmenter la
création de valeur oui il faut augmenter
les salaires je suis d'accord avec vous
mais on a déjà pas d'entreprises
on a déjà pas d'entreprises si ce n'est
des monopolistes comme vous les appelez
oui je suis d'accord pour qu'il faille
augmenter les rémunérations on essaye
sur les prestations sociales on va
essayer de bloquer cette affaire de des
retraites là qui baisse automatiquement
du
comment s'appelle Ikea de l'ittr oui
c'est un travail et un combat continu ce
que j'essaye de vous dire c'est que je
comprends que vous vouliez aller plus
vite
mais sur la hausse des prestations
sociales notamment mais elles ont
augmenté
pas suffisamment vite enfin suffisamment
vite on peut le penser aussi mais après
vous avez des questions d'équilibre
globaux qui fait que je pense pas qu'on
puisse aller plus vite sur les 6400
emplois
à la Réunion j'ai pas le détail mais il
faudra qu'on le trouve le chiffre c'est
je passe je ne pense pas que ça soit
inexact
6400 points on va essayer d'en faire la
liste imaginez que je me balade pas avec
la liste nominative de tous les emplois
dans les 12 territoires d'outre-mer
maintenant mais j'entends votre question
devant la commission devant la
commission des finances qui a 6400
emplois qui ont été créés à la Réunion
me semble-t-il le minimum c'est de
savoir de quel emploi on parle vous
pouvez pas annoncer un chiffre sans
derrière avoir quelque chose de concret
sur ces emplois là ce chiffre il vient
de quelque part donc à partir du moment
où vous le sortez vous devez savoir à
quoi il correspond c'est pas je me
permets c'est pas possible de nous dire
il y a 6400 emplois à la Réunion créée
mais ne pas savoir donc au moins dans
quel secteur quel type d'emploi je la
position veillera la commission
mais mes journées en 26 heures c'est
déjà deux de plus et mon cerveau est
limité mais vous posez une question j'y
répondrai j'y répondrai exactement même
les employeurs si vous voulez mais il
suffit mais vous pouvez le demander
aussi au préfet qui vous voulez mais
c'est bien
[Musique]
il faut y répondre baisse des charges
sont déjà pas très élevés
la question est
au moins jusqu'à un certain seuil après
ils sont existent est-ce qu'on bouge les
paramètres est-ce qu'on bouge les
paramètres de ces exonérations de charge
moi mon choix ma préférence
c'est créer des zones franches totales
dans chacune des capitales de chacun des
Drom Tom de manière à tirer de l'emploi
c'est plutôt ma préférence que je vais
proposer auxium en accord d'ailleurs
avec les présidents de ces collectivités
mais
faut-il baisser des charges sociales
pour les salaires supérieurs à deux SMIC
je suis pas sûr
augmenter la baisse des charges sociales
on crée une nouvelle ça fonctionne
plutôt bien
pour être plus attractif la proposition
des ministères c'est de créer des zones
franches totales en lisant avec les
grands élus en lisant avec les mères
pour faire de la transformation et de
l'emploi
prédéport c'est ça mon sujet sur les
baisses de charge ma réponse sur les
baisses de charges sociales
c'était vraiment est-ce que vous avez
des rapports qui permettent d'évaluer
réellement le coût enfin ou le bien
fondé des exonérations fiscales ça fait
30 ans que c'est le modèle dans les
outre-mer nous on a cherché peut-être
qu'on cherche mal mais la question que
je pose dans communiste d'État c'est sur
un ministre de l'État c'est de savoir
sur quoi sur quoi vous appuyez pour dire
que c'est bénéfique vous nous dites ces
bénéfique ça crée de l'emploi etc à
partir de quoi vous pouvez nous dire ça
est-ce qu'on a un début d'évaluation sur
effectivement le niveau de l'emploi
est-ce que effectivement ça crée de
l'emploi ou pas est-ce que ça peut
permettre d'augmenter les salaires ou
pas est-ce que en fait c'est reporté et
donc est-ce que vous avez des rapports
là-dessus parce que vous avez répondu à
mon collègue des virimens que
effectivement ça crée de l'emploi mais à
partir de quoi vous pouvez dire ça à
partir de quoi l'État par exemple sur
les questions des zones franches est-ce
que vous avez fait une évaluation des
zones France qui existe déjà il y en a
une dans l'est de la Réunion est-ce que
vous êtes allés voir si ça fonctionne ça
fonctionne pas pour pouvoir ensuite le
voilà c'est ça la question c'est pas le
temps de dire c'est bien c'est pas bien
c'est dire comment l'évaluer cette
politique publique qui depuis 30 ans
fait des exonérations de cotisations et
non pas de charge voilà est-ce qu'on
l'évalue et pour continuer pas continuer
à aller plus loin pas plus loin alors on
sait combien ça coûte ça doit être un
milliard quatre par an un milliard 4
c'est déjà pas mal
comment
c'est la moitié du budget de des deux
missions outre-mer c'est ce que vous
voulez dire c'est votre mère est
meilleur que
je n'ai pas
alors je peux vous répondre ça crée des
emplois la preuve c'est que les emplois
augmentent on va vous dire qui ou
comment
tous les entrepreneurs que je vois
me disent surtout ne touchez pas ça
c'est clair tous les élus responsables
de collectivités me disent touche pas à
ça
moi j'écoute beaucoup les présidents de
collectivités je les vois souvent
c'est eux qui demandent des des
zones franches totales
c'est eux qui l'ont mis dans mon esprit
et qu'ils ont mis sûrement sur mon
logiciel
et je pense que c'est c'est pas une
science exacte économie c'est pas une
science exacte la création de valeur
c'est d'essayer de trouver toujours
l'optimum entre le niveau de salaire le
niveau de charge publique et la création
d'emploi et la capacité de décision des
élus auxquelles il appartient de décider
si personne si aucun élu ne m'avait
demandé de zones franches totales l'idée
ne m'en serait pas venue
mais tous quel que soit leur couleur
politique la veulent
tous
à la Réunion à la Martinique à la
Guadeloupe en Guyane
pour prendre les principaux
on va essayer de voir ce que ça coûte
mais je pense que c'est aussi
on n'est pas dans une économie
totalement administrée c'est clair c'est
clair il y a des endroits où c'est
largement administré c'est l'électricité
l'énergie en tout cas mais la bonne
nouvelle en énergie c'est qu'on ne
manque pas d'énergie outre-mer
un petit peu à Saint-Martin si on y fait
rien mais normalement ça va l'évaluation
est toute une ligne
les jeunes franches nouvelles génération
on va essayer d'avoir une évaluation de
ce que ça coûterait
à la fin du premier trimestre 2025 si on
les a créé
[Musique]
sur le volet
la dernière question monsieur je réalise
c'était le volet impact des prix
outre-mer
c'est juste vous prenez le prix et vous
rajoutez une taxe je dis pas que c'est
négatif ça se pose pas comme ça ça c'est
vertu mais ça fait monter les prix quand
vous avez un octobre maire de 20% sur la
farine ça fait monter les prix de 20 %
sur la farine par rapport à votre mère
était à 0
hein c'est comme ça le droit de mer dans
mon esprit
un ne se changera pas s'il y a pas
l'accord de tout le monde
deux doit protéger les productions
locales or il ne protège plus les
productions locales il protège certes
les productions locales mais aussi c'est
juste un impôt à la consommation
sur la farine c'est juste en plus quand
on fait venir un
truc scanner il est pas fabriqué
localement
pouf on paye enfin c'est la sécu donc
c'est juste ça augmente les prix
d'autant que prenez l'exemple de la
Réunion ou ou madame Bello elle a fait
des efforts considérables sur les autres
mers ça a tenu les prix
c'est ni bien Nimal c'est juste une
constatation que nul ne peut nier que
quand ça vaut 100 et vous mettez un
impôt de vin dessus mais à la fin ça
fait 120
mais c'est pas un jugement de valeur
c'est juste de mathématiques classe
primaire
bien mais après il faut le remplacer il
faut le remplacer par quelque chose qui
est un peu plus vertueux
de pouvoir tenir un peu les délais pour
autant je ferai de réaction je vous
propose pour la suite on se dit ce qu'on
les interventions sont deux trois
minutes pour chacun en jetons ce qui
permettra de fluidifier quitte à ce que
si jamais des questions qui doit être
posées ensuite on revoit pour une un
tour supplémentaire je peux aider des
personnes mais juste qu'on essaie cet
échange qui soit interactif et pour
autant je vais pas suivre l'exemple
parce que est-ce que dans les
interventions qui viennent d'avoir lieu
il y a deux il y a deux décorrélations
qui vous sont demandées est-ce qu'on
peut demander à l'INSEE par exemple
d'avoir
une analyse spécifique sur les biens de
consommation non administré sur les
niveaux des prix parce que c'est ce que
j'ai compris c'est que vous considérez
nos collègues considèrent que la
relative modération de la hausse des
prix tient au fait qu'il y a beaucoup de
prix qui sont administrés et que ça ne
traduit pas la vérité de la du prix au
quotidien est-ce que je traduis mal
c'est donc est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir
tout le monde Aline c'est d'avoir cette
statistiques là et par ailleurs du coup
ne croyez-vous pas que ça voudrait le
coup qu'il y ait aussi une forme de
décorrélation du niveau d'augmentation
des prestations sociales en fonction de
cette réalité là et pas uniquement d'un
niveau qui nettoie ce qui serait qui
serait national confondant l'hexagone et
l'outre-mer
globalement je comprends pas très bien
les questions prenez quand les prix sont
réglementés c'est moins cher
carburant carburant je continue
si on enlevait ses prix là la hausse
générale du reste des prix j'ai encore
une fois je je
serai les prix de l'alimentation par
exemple est-ce qu'on a par exemple
est-ce qu'on a une alimentation et bien
en Martinique c'est 5,5 certial bqp+ en
Guyane c'est 7,2 en métropole c'est 12,7
encore une fois ça s'applique sur pas
sur la même population et sur un niveau
de prix qui démarre de plus haut j'ai
bien entendu ça je m'en félicite pas
juste je suis pour l'exactitude des
chiffres mais quand ça augmente
de X pour cent
outre-mer alors que le prix est déjà
plus élevé qu'en métropole effectivement
c'est une importance plus forte mais la
vérité c'est que ça augmente moins
c'est juste pour bien préciser une chose
quand on prend le cas de l'énergie qui
était l'un des facteur inflationniste
non négligeable ces derniers mois je
rappelle que l'énergie sur nos
territoires les prix ne bougent pas que
si le gouvernement augmente le prix de
l'électricité d'accord ce qui n'a pas
été le cas pour les collectivités pour
les entreprises les grosses boîtes qui
qui produisent qui font des choses qui
étaient sur des marchés qui étaient sur
le marché ou les prix ont explosé et
c'est bien pour ça que je dis si le prix
augmente plus difficilement son
territoire par rapport à l'Hexagone
c'est bien parce que par exemple il est
pris son administrer il y a un plafond
qui ne peuvent pas dépasser tels que
l'électricité et le carburant ce qui
n'est pas le cas sur le territoire et
c'est bien pour ça que ces différents
inflation donc j'ai bien dit lorsque
l'État met la main sur différentes
choses on voit bien que les prix ne
s'envolent pas voilà
alors je répète maintenant passer la
parole afin yeah et ensuite notre
collègue Niort oui merci monsieur le
Président je vais faire court parce
qu'un certain nombre de sujets ont été
ou de thèmes ont été évoqués par les
collègues la première chose il faut à
chaque fois rappeler les collègues en
raison lorsqu'on dit que l'inflation est
moins sur nos territoires que dans
l'Hexagone il faut répéter à chaque fois
moindre mais sur des prix un coup de la
vie déjà plus élevé il faut le dire et
il faut d'autant plus pondérer ce cet
argument qui consiste à dire que
l'inflation est moine si je prends le
cas de la Réunion monsieur le ministre
si l'inflation d'avril 2022 avril de
cette année était de 3,3%, une étude
récente de l'Insee montre que or produit
frais les prix augmenter de 9,4% donc il
faut vraiment et les collègues en raison
il faut pondérer tout cela ça c'est la
première chose que je voulais dire la
deuxième chose que je voulais dire c'est
que on voit bien que il y a des causes
qui sont structurelles par rapport à la
Ferté de la vie il y a des causes qui
viennent de loin il y a
incontestablement des abus des
situations de monopole de l'icopole etc
il faut absolument aujourd'hui je pense
encourager la production locale on est
dans une partie de bras de fer entre les
importations et la production locale il
faut mettre le paquet sur la production
locale et il faut et si je prends le cas
de la réunion très rapidement
la production locale les filières sont
une réalité sur la viande de porc sur la
viande de volaille sur la viande de la
paire aujourd'hui la production locale
couvre sans je parle du frais couvre
100% du marché local donc il faut mettre
le paquet là-dessus et j'ai une question
par rapport à ça c'est qu'est-ce que
vous comptez faire vraiment dans cette
partie là et tout le monde ne sera pas
pour la production locale parce que ceux
qui gagnent de l'argent en faisant venir
des produits à la Réunion et qui gagnent
beaucoup d'argent vous pensez bien
qu'ils vont trouver toutes sortes de
frais et vont s'opposer à cela donc ça
c'est qu'est-ce que vous comptez faire
ma mon autre question est la suivante
l'article 73 de la loi égalité réelle
encourager justement dans un domaine
différent puisqu'on est sur la création
de valeur etc encourager les petites les
moyennes entreprises à travers un
dispositif qui permettait de réserver
une partie de la commande publique aux
petites entreprises à titre expérimental
c'était l'article 73 de la loi égalité
réelle ça n'a pas marché il faut le dire
ça n'a pas marché est-ce que vous
comptez travailler de nouveau là dessus
parce qu'il faut donner il faut j'ai
envie de dire il faut donner du business
à nos petites entreprises réunionnaises
antillaise et ailleurs parce que encore
une fois si les entreprises se
développent et ben forcément il y a
création d'emploi et s'il y a création
d'emploi ce sont des revenus qui tombent
et percevalent la très bien dit dans la
charité de la vie dans le la charte de
la vie bien sûr il y a les prix mais il
y a aussi la faiblesse des revenus donc
ça c'est une chose et dernière chose je
n'en aurai terminé à la Réunion subit
une double peine actuellement c'est une
vraie bombe à retardement c'est la
question du logement on subit la double
peine pourquoi parce qu'il y a plus de
logements aidé je parle des logements
aidés pour le moment ce qu'on appelle
les logements sociaux plus de logement
aidés qui sortent de terre il y a un
véritable effondrement de la production
ça c'est la première chose je dis la
double peine pourquoi parce que chez
nous monsieur le ministre vous savez les
loyers je parle du LLTS les loyers sont
plus élevés ou au moins aussi élevé que
dans certaines régions de l'Hexagone
alors que nos locataires sont plus
pauvres que dans l'Hexagone notamment
les familles monoparentales et il y a un
travail à faire là-dessus très
rapidement c'est le travail sur
l'importation des matériaux aujourd'hui
il faut faire ce travail là sur les
nobles il faut qu'on ait une autorité
qui puisse certifier les normes il faut
qu'on arrête de faire venir de la
dématériaux d'Europe il faut regarder
son bassin régional il faudrait sur les
lampes est-ce que vous comptez agir
là-dessus concrètement et fortement je
sais bien que la question du logement
social c'est plusieurs aspects il y a
pas que celui-là il y a le foncier
également que cher mais c'est un vrai
sujet pour les Réunionnais aujourd'hui
merci
merci merci d'avoir
tenues monsieur du Nord je vous referai
pas mon grand exemples du BA13 versus le
ba11 donc l'épaisseur du placo qui nous
oblige à importer de du Havre tous les
Black Ops
oui monsieur le ministre lorsqu'on
compare les tournées façons mes
collègues ont évoqué cette question là
il faut être particulièrement prudent
lorsqu'on parle de comparaison entre
inflation dans l'Hexagone inflation dans
nos territoires pour plusieurs raisons
mais la première c'est que un taux de 4%
d'augmentation
soit un montant de 100 euros
ça fait bien plus au final ça fait une
augmentation de 4 euros 4%
d'augmentation sur 100 euros ça fait un
prix qui augmente qui atteint 104 euros
c'est plus que 6% d'augmentation sur un
produit qui vaut 50 euros
puisque là c'est un delta de plus 3 + 3
euros donc lorsqu'on parle de
pourcentage sur des valeurs qui sont
différentes
on risque de se tromper et ça peut être
involontaire ou volontaire
mais je sais que vous vous ne pouvez pas
me laisser finir une intervention je
suis ministre
pour le dire dans quelques minutes
non mais monsieur le ministre je sais
que c'est plus fort que vous ça vous
démange dès que je commence à parler il
faut que vous mettez en pied mais c'est
plus fort que vous c'est ce qu'il dit là
restez sur vos questions
alors donc il faut faire attention à ça
et par rapport à ce phénomène
la proposition
d'un SMIC outremé en Majorie et de
prestation sociale majorées c'est pour
une proposition qui relève tout
simplement de la justice sociale parce
qu'à l'état reconnaît cette réalité de
la vie chère pour ses fonctionnaires
très bien
ce n'est pas un privilège
c'est simplement une reconnaissance de
cette réalité de la vie chère mais la
vie est chère dans les supermarchés
partout dans les prestations de service
aussi bien pour ceux qui travaillent
dans le privé avec des petits salaires
et aussi bien pour ceux qui sont
bénéficiaires je sais pas si on peut
toujours utiliser ce terme de
bénéficiaire ce qui subissent les
minimas sociaux les prestations sociales
la vie est aussi cher pour eux
donc c'est une question de justice tout
simplement
d'autres choses d'autre part sur la
question du transport aérien je serai
clair
vous dites que pour revenir sur les
situations de Joe Paul monopole
oligopole plus ou moins bonne
il faut de l'activité de la création de
valeur
mais ça ne se fait pas comme ça
objectivement il faut tenir compte d'un
certain nombre de choses mais les
situations de blocage de projet
de
situation de blocage qui sont dues à
l'action de ceux qui sont en position
dominante sur les marchés on ne rentre
pas comme ça sur certains marchés dans
nos territoires vous le savez et puis
c'est ne pas tenir compte aussi de la
frilosité des banques avec certains
chez nous les banques sont beaucoup plus
frileuses pour accorder des crédits aux
entreprises pour l'investissement c'est
beaucoup plus facile que d'accorder des
crédits pour l'achat d'un véhicule
particulier par exemple
donc
nous subissons par rapport à ça parce
qu'il faut savoir de quelle inflation on
parle il y a inflation par les coûts mon
chat collègue je suis désolé je sens que
d'aucun et je le comprends sont allés
voter pour le soutien oui mais moi aussi
je souhaite voter je termine ma question
voilà c'est ce que c'est exactement ce
que je voulais dire
il y a l'inflation par les coups mais
aussi l'inflation par la demande
et s'agissant du marché de l'accès aux
fonciers dans notre territoire je parle
de la Martinique particulièrement ce
foncier de plus en plus inaccessible
pour les résidents les ressortissants de
nos territoires un jeune couple en
Martinique ne peut plus acheter de
fonciers parce que les prix ont explosé
et ça ça doit aussi entrer dans les dans
les calculs des taux d'inflation que
vous nous donnez donc nous sommes de
fait exclus de nos territoires et c'est
excessivement grave ce qui se passe
parce qu'il y a une demande extérieure
des gens qui ont davantage de moyens qui
viennent qui se positionnent et qui
proposent des prix qui sont
inatteignables pour nous donc ça c'est
aussi une réalité de nos territoires qui
s'opposent avec beaucoup d'acuités enfin
sur les transports aériens vous parlez
de défiscalisation etc je vous rappelle
et d'abandon de créances que ça ne
profite pas une finnée au peuple mais
accompagné aériennes qui ne répercute
pas systématiquement
sur les prix et puis ce que nous voulons
c'est un service public de transport
et un service public de transport avec
la création d'un délégation de service
public de transport c'est la seule
solution pour faire baisser et maintenir
les prix ad niveaux décent la seule
solution leur reste l'augmentation du
budget de la Dom etc tout ça part de
bons sentiments mais on est dans la
fragilité on est dans la précarité on
veut un modèle comme la cause comme ce
qui a été mis en place encore et qui
fait ses preuves dans le cas de l'accord
voilà j'en ai terminé
alors je me suis ministre je vais être
obligé de pouvoir méditer sur vos
réponses parce que le
traditionnel sur la loi de programmation
militaire
qui doit qui doit encore un orateur
alors je vous laisse votre titre réponse
allez-y
je suis d'accord avec vous je le dis
pour la dixième fois
vingtième fois l'inflation te dit elle
est plus faible en valeur comme ça mais
je participe totalement au fait que ça
ne veut pas dire la même chose je l'ai
dit je le redis donc voilà essayer de
croire que je vous ai compris
par contre là il faut vraiment qu'on
suspente parce que là ce parcours tu
pourrais reprendre la parole après
t'inquiète pas il y a pas il s'agit pas
de brider qui que ce soit juste d'aller
voter parce que c'est une demande qui
m'a été faite par vos collègues vous
savez il y a plus de gens de la Major de
l'opposition que la majorité vous je
pourrais jouer à scotcher tout le monde
j'ai juste encore une fois cette
distension temporaire
allez-y chers collègues merci beaucoup
monsieur Miss parfait donc écoutez mes
collègues vous ont beaucoup interrogé
sur ce que vous entreprendrez
prochainement pour régler le problème de
la de la vie chère outre-mer vous-même
n'avez pas résisté à la tentation de
nous annoncer que pour 23 24 25 vous
aviez des projets on pourrait résoudre
ce problème simplement
pour ma part je considère que nous
sommes dans commission d'enquête pour
établir les causes et les
responsabilités de la situation actuelle
de la vie chère donc tout ce qui est
prospectif va très bien et nous sommes
heureux d'avoir pu constater vos
excellents dispositions à cet égard
c'est le ministre mais mes questions
vont être donc rétrospectives comme il
se doit pour une commission d'enquête
j'ai sous les yeux les recommandations
datant de 2019 de la l'Autorité de la
concurrence à propos de l'octroi de mer
je lis juste trois recommandations très
rapidement
donc il s'agit le titre c'est évaluer
les conditions d'application de notre
droit de mère recommandations numéro 3
simplifier la grille des taux d'octroi
de mer et la rendre cohérente entre
territoires géographiquement proche
numéro 4 réexaminer les taux applicables
aux produits importés pour lesquels
inexistent pas d'équivalent dans la
production locale et numéro 5 simplifié
système d'exonération des intrants donc
ce sont des propositions qui émanent
d'une autorité publique elles sont 2019
vous avez probablement trouvé sur votre
bureau en arrivant dans le dossier
ministériel donc ma question est simple
pourquoi n'avez rien entrepris ou pour
quelle raison je ne sais pas politique
technique que sais-je n'avez-vous rien
d'entrepris pendant votre première année
de de ministère pour prendre à bras le
corps ce problème qui est archi connu et
décrit par toutes les administrations
nous avons eu récemment la directrice
générale d'outre-mer qui nous en a parlé
avec beaucoup de honnêteté et ma seconde
question c'est de revenir sur la sur la
question de la continuité territoriale
j'ai une fiche ainsi qui m'indique que
la continuité territoriale ultramarine
est soutenu par l'État à hauteur de 45
millions d'euros de subventions pour 2,7
millions d'habitants tandis qu'elle est
soutenue par l'État à 190 millions
d'euros de subventions pour l'accord ce
qui compte 330 000 habitants
qu'avez-vous entrepris
que comptez-vous entreprendre mais
qu'avez-vous entrepris déjà pour
corriger cette inégalité criante je vous
remercie
très bien cette position justement
laisser le temps notre collègue ni
l'heure de revenir donc monsieur le
ministre vous allez pouvoir répondre à
cette salle de question en présence de
ce qui vous les ont posé
si vous permettez je répondais c'est
plus simple sur le droit de mère
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a rien fait parce
que les élus n'en veulent pas
et mon travail depuis
10 mois c'est d'essayer de les
convaincre qu'on doit faire qu'on peut
faire il est propositions précises leur
ont été faites je souhaite le raccord et
je pense que nous n'obtiendrons le sujet
de modification de notre mère telle que
je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure sera
proposé au somme j'ai l'accord du
ministère des Finances je pense avoir
l'accord de madame la Première ministre
et derrière j'irai chercher l'accord
mais je pense que je l'aurai de la part
des exécutifs territoriaux
je ne déciderai pas
contre la vie des exécutifs et des
assemblées territoriales sur la réforme
de l'octer
une réponse simple mais dès le début on
a commencé à y travailler on a élaboré
ces propositions qui sont maintenant
connus de la part
des exécutifs territoriaux responsables
de notre mère
s'il y a si c'est incompréhensible
c'est à moi à moins qu'on dise l'état
reprend tout en main c'est pas du tout
la mission qui m'est donnée c'est
d'arriver à construire collectivement
quelque chose je pense qu'en 8 mois il
faut bien découvrir les choses
on s'est mis sur le bon chemin sur la
réforme que j'évoquais
quant à la continuité territoriale
j'aurais pas aussi à l'idée peut-être de
Monsieur milord ou de Monsieur maïs je
sais pas
supposons des fois je suis tenté
de dire et pourquoi un service public de
transport
mais ce qui aurait pu
il y aurait plus qu'une compagnie
c'est ce qui se passe à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon il n'y a pas
d'avion il y a plus l'avion il n'y a
plus que
12 volts dans l'année en direct et ça
coûte alors une fortune et personne veut
y aller à ce tarif là personne veut y
aller
et donc l'idée d'une service public ça
veut dire qu'il y aurait plus qu'une
seule compagnie
ou alors
si c'est pour avoir le même prix que les
autres ça sert à rien si ça va si c'est
pour avoir un prix plus bas si une
compagnie mais la réflexion elle est
dans ma tête aussi
c'est un vrai sujet c'est ce qu'on a
en Guyane interne ça marche pas
ça marche pas pour différents
ça ne marche pas
oui
et on va le dire on peut le dire
pourquoi ça marche pas en tout cas j'ai
deux endroits où ça existe
une il n'y a pas d'avion il m'en mettre
que 11 par an et je veux renégocier
l'ensemble du sujet et je suis en train
de chercher d'autres compagnies pour
venir desservir Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
où il y a que 6500 habitants à peine il
faut les trouver les gens pour y aller
et oui et sur
la Guyane en vol interne ça marche pas
parce que la compagnie telle qu'elle est
structurée ne marche pas qu'il nous faut
inventer une autre compagnie
mais c'est pas et l'accord s'il y a
d'abord un
sur les prix
au prix du kilomètre parcouru on peut
trouver que c'est pas bien on est en
moyenne à 4,9 centimes pour les
outre-mer
c'est ce qu'on trouve de moins cher dans
le monde c'est ce qu'on trouve de moins
cher dans le monde
entre parer des Outre-mer ces 4,9
centimes le prix du kilomètre parcouru
pour l'Amérique du Sud c'est 6,8 pour
l'Afrique subsaharienne c'est 9,5
centimes du kilomètre donc on a un vrai
sujet mais toutes les idées sont bonnes
à travailler
en bonne à travailler je les rejette pas
d'un revers de main
je dis simplement que là où il y a des
DSP
pour différentes raisons
différents ça marche pas et donc ça
interroge un peu ça interroge et sur les
deux on y travaille pour trouver un
système qui fasse d'abord qui a un
service et qui soit au moindre coût et
qui soit au moindre coût mais je
donnerai les chiffres précis lorsqu'on
les aura sur la comparaison entre
l'outre-mer les Antilles notamment et la
Corse et la Corse
sur
la Réunion par exemple
c'est quasiment le
la région qui fait les prix
majoritaire qui fait les prix
et il fait des prix et on va essayer de
le soutenir encore pour que ça marche
mon souci c'est que le sauvetage de la
compagnie Air australe
sur lequel j'ai été volontariste au côté
de Madame Bello
ne s'arrête pas dans 2 ans
ne s'arrête pas dans deux ans
avec une compagnie qui ne
réussirait pas à voler dans des
conditions
normales dans des conditions normales il
faut aider sur je répète les sujets des
délais voyageurs sujets d'aider
là où on a un vrai sujet c'est qu'à la
différence de ce qui se passe sur le
transport routier par exemple on a des
prix administrés on n'a pas de prix
administré sur le kérosène
là dans la discussion
ce que je retiens tout est bon à prendre
comme il est
c'est le sujet du prix du kérosène
est-ce que on doit aller vers là
c'est le débat que j'ai par exemple avec
la Sarah
compliqué
débat sur la Sarra est un débat les plus
que je connaisse outre-mer parce que
d'abord c'est des centaines d'emplois
c'est de la création de valeur c'est
comment on transforme
cette société historique historique
c'est pas là quand on a signé le taux de
marge
il est largement supérieur
à ce qu'on faisait quand j'étais à la
creux mais c'est comme ça c'est signé
ceci dit les discussions elles sont
largement entamées avec la Sarah si je
retiens une idée de ce débat de ce qu'on
peut faire peut-être en plus
c'est le prix du kérosène
je pense que la vérité elle est elle est
plutôt là
j'ai pas entendu pardon je vous suggère
une piste c'est l'origine du kérosène et
en tout cas des carburants d'une manière
générale nous on
va l'acheter le chercher en Europe alors
qu'il y a du carburant beaucoup moins
cher plus proche de nos territoires et
lorsque vous parlez de de meilleur
encoche dans le territoire Vénézuela
c'est plus proche que que la mère du
Nord ou le Danemark le débat c'est bien
tout le débat des normes on revient au
BTP etc les normes et des sujets
européens on a aussi la Sarah qui est
aux normes françaises si j'ose dire et
c'est aussi un monopole un vrai monopole
et c'est un sujet dont on débat ardiman
et ardemment avec la Sarah il y a tout
le sujet d'énormes européennes pour
qu'il y ait de l'eau
à Saint-Martin parce que l'usine est en
panne à ma faute si l'usine est en panne
je pense que le délégataire il est
collectivités ont pas bien fait ce qu'il
fallait au bon moment
j'ai dit 21 on pourrait acheter de l'eau
chez les Hollandais à Saint-Martin ils
en ont
c'est ce qu'on a fait aussi avec lui
apporter de Maurice à Mayotte c'est un
combat c'est le sujet des normes
européennes je l'ai gagné en apportera
de l'eau de Saint-Martin à Saint-Martin
librement
il faut se battre à chaque fois
oui les normes européennes construction
c'est un axe de de combat
éminent amener je pense que on est en
train de le gagner sur deux trois sujets
ce qui nous fait perdre sur d'autres
affaires mais peu importe en tout cas
les normes européennes les normes
européennes sont un vrai sujet et il
nous faut combattre en permanence pour
dès qu'il y a un intérêt loi
Saint-Martin
l'oie Mayotte le carburant
[Musique]
par exemple
ou si vous achetez du pétrole au
Suriname il vaut moins cher que si vous
achetez à La Sarraz
et ça n'abîme pas davantage les voitures
d'aiguannées d'acheter de du carburant
sur une arme donc les normes européennes
je sais pas je n'ai
que seuls les abîme pas tout seul les
abîme pas et que je pense qu'il y en a
qui le font douce
et ça marche ça ne détruit pas les
voitures européennes parce qu'on y met
de l'essence sauf que j'essaye de faire
les choses
plutôt légalement et réglementairement
et ça vaut notamment pour toutes les
normes CE sur les produits de
construction
le débat est plus que lancé
j'espère qu'on va sortir de ces normes
je pense notamment la réunion sur les
normes de produits de produits pour le
bâtiment qui sont alors on a autour
on a autour donc ça c'est un vrai un
vrai sujet
sur la création de valeur et les charges
je rappelle que la BPI aujourd'hui
soutient largement les petites
entreprises avec des prêts avec ceci des
garanties etc sur l'argent du ministère
de l'Outre-mer tout ça c'est pas c'est
pas une bonne action pure
que les prêts de la FD sont aussi
financés garantis par le ministère de
l'Outre-mer l'hypothèse sur laquelle
nous travaillons
j'ai rencontré
Bruno Bonnel de la SGPI et hier Nicolas
Dufour de la BPI c'est d'essayer de
créer une société d'investissement
d'investissement dans des entreprises
créateurs de valeur dans les outre-mer
qu'on est un fond d'investissement
libre qui ne soit qui ne soit guidés que
par la création de valeur et la création
d'emploi outre-mer sans autre
considération sans autre considération
nous souhaitons si la mission qui m'est
que je me suis donné qu'ils aient fait
valider avoir cette société
d'investissement avec des capitaux
publics pour garantir la solidité du
sujet mais avec des sociétés privées qui
viendraient au capital je pense que j'en
ai trouvé une ou deux pour l'instant
j'aimerais doter cette société on en
parlait hier d'environ 50 millions
de capacités d'investissement ce qui est
beaucoup trop mer pour commencer puis si
ça marche ça se développerait quant à la
production locale dans le bqp plus et je
salue l'action l'action de la région
on impose 40% de produits locaux 40%
fait que ça soit partout pareil déjà
pour commencer mais 40%
et j'ai pas de retour négatif de la part
des entreprises de distribution elles
s'y soumettent finalement
avec relativement de bonne humeur si
j'ose dire relativement de bonne humeur
quant aux données l'article 73 les les
retours d'analyse sont annoncés alors
quand on fait des gros rapports comme ça
ça prend toujours un temps plus long que
raisonnable vous savez un temps plus
long que l'homme que ça mais rien
n'empêche aujourd'hui
dans les donneurs d'ordre qui sont
globalement les collectivités locales
vous le savez bien
de faire des lots d'alotir
si vous faites un lot énorme de tout
évidemment vous trouverez pas de petites
entrepreneurs locaux mais si vous faites
des petits lots des lots accessibles
ça marche
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire ensemble
avec les donneurs d'ordre public sont
pas l'état et donneurs d'Orbe public
faites des lots on pourra les financer
plus vite elles seront garanties plus
vite j'ajoute que pour revenir sur notre
croix de mer
que la difficulté de l'octroi de mer
c'est que vous le payez avant d'avoir
vendu
ça ça augmente le prix de production
quand vous êtes à de la TVA vous la
payez que quand vous avez vendu c'est un
impôt après vente en mer est un impôt à
binicieux à Vénissieux et si ça marche
vous le récupérer ça marche pas vous le
récupérez pas d'où l'idée qu'il faut un
peu changer et qu'on est en train de
changer
sur le réponse sur l'alimentation les
réponses qui ont été donnés pendant la
Première ministre à la Réunion se met en
place tout ça est validé l'aide aux
intrants notamment pour l'élevage c'est
un des vrais sujets ça fonctionne
conseil général le même dit qu'ils
compretterait la somme parce qu'il fait
réserver une somme pour ça auprès de mon
collègue Marc fedo et je dis aux
collectivités locales allez-y faites un
peu plus
Conseil Général de la Réunion est
d'accord pour abonder
cette aide aux intrants de l'élevage
c'est de l'aide aux intrants de
l'élevage ça se met en place sans état
d'âme
ça va être annoncé au fur et à mesure
tout ça l'administration française est
parfois un peu longue tandis qu'on vient
pas mais ça
c'est fait
c'est acquis des acquis de la demande
des agriculteurs la demande des
politiques ne vous faites partie après
il faut le mettre en place
[Musique]
sur le SMIC je vais répondre à Monsieur
mignon
au moins autant que vous
je souhaite que le pouvoir d'achat
augmente outre-mer
la question est celle de l'équilibre
déjà
oui oui
je souhaite que ça augmente et que
le pouvoir d'achat des ultramarins
soit le même
dans la République c'est quand même ça
le sujet c'est ça le sujet et c'est ça
l'objectif que je pense nous partageons
après il est normal
qu'il y a un exécutif
quasi d'abord en fonction des lois qui
sont votées et qui essayent de garder
des équilibres et qui est une opposition
qui disent que on doit aller plus vite
et plus loin je l'entends je l'admets
et j'essaye d'aller plus vite possible
bien
je vais faire un acte de vérité en
disant que je n'arriverai pas à vous
libérer dans 8 minutes et qu'on va
essayer de limiter le retard avec lequel
on va vous libérer j'ai passé la parole
successivement à notre collègue Bassir
et me fera non et après notre rapporteur
pour une dernière salle de question en
faisant que les interventions soient
condensées et plus de réponse le soit
aussi évidemment pour ne pas trop vous
retarder dans la suite de votre agenda
merci monsieur le Président bonjour à
tous monsieur le ministre vous avez dit
que pour vous il fallait mettre vraiment
l'action sur l'accent pardon sur la
création d'Alleur et vous en avez parlé
en plusieurs fois est-ce que vous
envisagez de faire bénéficier certains
secteurs et notamment du BTP puisque
nous avons parlé du logement et du
manque criant de logement sur l'ensemble
des territoires
ultramarins de de faire donc bénéficier
certains secteurs de la compétitivité
renforcée et
concrètement quel par quelle mesure et
pourrait-on également envisager toujours
pour la création de valeur la création
d'une zone franche globale à l'export
pour développer l'activité et l'emploi à
la Réunion et ainsi rendre notre
territoire plus attractifs pas seulement
sur le plan des charges sociales mais
également en termes de bénéfices sur du
label français et de conf ormité aux
normes européennes voilà je vous
remercie
merci de votre concision monsieur
merci président monsieur le ministre
l'article 63 de la loi et Rome devenu
article
410-6 du code du commerce permet
d'expérimentation sur la base de
négociations du principe d'un tarif
grossiste destiné aux petits commerces
sans à Mayotte et en Guyane le cas
échéant c'est le préfet qui impose les
prix il devrait rentrer en vigueur au
1er juillet 2017 pour une durée de 5 ans
quel bilan de ce dispositif et pourquoi
ne pas les tendre à tout l'outre-mer
c'est ma première question et puis pour
aller vite faut-il activer
pour y répondre
devenu article 410-6 du code du commerce
permet d'expérimentation sur la barre de
négociation du principe d'un tarif
grossiste destiné aux petits commerçants
à Mayotte et en Guyane
le cas échéant c'est le préfet qui
impose les prix
il devrait entrer en vigueur le 1er
juillet 2017 pour une durée de 5 ans
quel bilan
et pourquoi ne pas les tendre à
l'ensemble des Outre-mer
faut-il autre question faut-il activer
le levier des échanges commerciaux entre
les
pays des différents bassins
géographiques pour limiter
l'implantation dont la facture s'est
envolée avec l'augmentation conséquent
du coût du fret maritime
pour finir après le dino du pouvoir
d'achat rien n'a vraiment changé dans la
vie des ultramarins contrairement ce que
vous dites avez-vous vraiment consulté
l'ensemble des acteurs et les
parlementaires des outre-mer pour le
somme est-ce qu'il sera question de la
vie chère
pour qu'on le somme avons-nous une date
et puis est-ce que les parlementaires
seront associés
merci chers collègues de votre concision
aussi monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci vous avez un collaborateur
s'appelle Max Dubois
chargé des Outre-mer vous avez mis face
à son contrat alors que il avait pour
mission de travailler notamment de
lutter contre les problématiques
d'oligopole le monopole
pourquoi première question
deuxième question vous parlez de
l'octroi de mer
et personne ne dit que l'octroi de mer
dont je comprends qui est le
bouc émissaire des problématiques
d'autres fluctuelles
l'octroi de l'emploi aussi dans ces
territoires et que l'argent de l'octroi
de mer reste sur les territoires did
outre-mer
par contre la TVA qui représente en
volume autant que l'octobre mais il y a
quasiment un milliard d'euros repart ça
veut dire que la richesse écrite sur les
territoires un milliard et c'est un
milliard repartent en des territoires 10
d'outre-mer
que comptez-vous faire pour faire en
sorte sachant que l'octroi de mer est
sous la main des politiques
territoriales alors que la TVA est sous
la main du gouvernement directement que
comptez-vous faire pour faire en sorte
que ce milliard d'euros créé par les
peuples de ces territoires eux-mêmes
puissent bénéficier justement de cette
recette pour créer de l'activité et
créer de l'emploi dans ces territoires
et non pas repartir
autre élément le fond exceptionnel
d'investissement pareil il récupère la
fin
l'abaissement de l'abattement fiscal
payer par les ménages des territoires
des d'outre-mer pour environ 70 millions
d'euros des 110 millions d'euros et cet
argent c'est à financer des territoires
les plus pauvres des territoires
d'outre-mer c'est à dire qu'on fait
financer les territoires d'outre-mer par
d'autres territoires d'outre-mer un peu
moins pauvres que ceux qui sont les très
pauvres je parle de Mayotte et de Guyane
sont mieux financiers très bien mais au
détriment finalement du pouvoir d'achat
parce que c'est l'impôt sur le revenu
des ménages des territoires de
Martinique Guadeloupe réunion qui
aujourd'hui se retrouve avec un
abattement fiscal moindre alors que
l'abattement fiscal c'était justement
pour compenser une problématique
d'autres structurelle à la fois de
l'Isère et de diminution des services de
l'État dans ces territoires là
troisièmement
pouvez-vous vous engager à lancer
puisqu'on est en 2023 malgré le rapport
de l'Autorité de la concurrence en 2009
il n'y a eu aucune étude sérieuse sur
l'accumulation des marges des grands
groupes notamment des oligopoles et des
monopoles pouvez-vous vous engager en
tant que ministre a lancé cette étude
profonde de façon à ce qu'on puisse
déterminer en toute transparence la
réalité aujourd'hui des accumulations
des marges d'autre part vous avez dit
que l'inflation
si on en prend uniquement la base
français hexagonale sur une donnée une
période donnée
est plus forte dans les territoires de
la France hexagonale plutôt qu'on était
étoile d'outre-mer il y a un élément
sous les prix réglementés qu'il faut
prendre en compte c'est que nos
territoires dit d'outre-mer en des
capacités de stockage puisque comme le
marché est exigu ils sont obligés de
stocker pas seulement dans l'énergie
mais dans tous les domaines ça veut dire
que il y a eu un retard à l'inflation
parce que ce qui s'est passé c'est que
les stocks étant plein avant la crise ce
sont les stocks des prix anciens qui ont
été consommés maintenant il faut
reconstituer les stocks ça veut dire que
dans les six mois qui viennent il y aura
une inflation qui va
s'accélérer dans nos territoires parce
que les stocks ont été reconstitués avec
des produits dont les prix sont
actualisés que comptez-vous faire pour
lutter contre l'inflation conjonctuelle
qui vient s'ajouter aussi au coût de la
vie et puis sous la question de la
concurrence
il y a j'ai proposé d'ailleurs j'ai
remis une fiche en tant que
député mais avec d'autres députés la
création d'une quatrième compagnie
aérienne parce que il faut augmenter la
concurrence si on veut baisser les prix
avec Airbus et le CREFO
qu'on acceptez-vous de porter ce projet
et de le soutenir pour qu'il y ait une
quatrième compagnie aérienne pour
justement qu'il y ait plus de
concurrence dans nos territoires et puis
l'Autorité de la concurrence n'utilise
pas la jonctions structuelles vous avez
le pouvoir de le faire donc pouvez-vous
utiliser ce pouvoir de faire en sorte
que les structures d'État qui agissent
sur le contrôle à la fois des
problématiques de marge et des
problématiques de concurrence de
pratiques anti-concurentielles mais
aussi sur toutes les problématiques de
Lego Paul de monopole puissent utiliser
ce pouvoir d'injonction structurelle
merci
vous avez votre centre l'humain aussi le
ministre puisque maintenant c'est à vous
de répondre et donc il le dépassement de
l'horaire dépend de vous des étirements
nous attendons attendons néanmoins des
réponses complètes quoi Monsieur
Hajar
ici comme c'est enregistré c'est
officiel je veux dire les choses
monsieur Dubois n'a jamais pu comprendre
qu'il était dans un cabinet ministériel
un cabinet ministériel
ça a ses avantages et ses inconvénients
mais une dérègle c'est quand des
solidaires de ses collègues du cabinet
et la deuxième règle c'est qu'il faut
que ces activités de cabinet sont
compatibles et déclaré compatible par
l'Autorité de la concurrence
l'autorité de la chatte et pardon à chat
TVP je suis pas sûr puisqu'il ne m'a pas
montré malgré ma demande
ce document que ça soit le cas mon petit
doigt me dit que c'est plutôt pas le cas
mais on s'est quitté
du moment monsieur Dubois j'en ai aucune
animosité ne sait pas ce que un travail
de cabinet il est un je pensais qu'il y
arriverait parce que je l'aimais bien je
l'aime toujours bien
mais moi je sais pas les chanter l'opéra
voilà et je me propose pas de le faire
il faut être dans une équipe il a pas su
s'intégrer à cette équipe c'est aussi
simple que ça
sur l'octroie de mer je me répète parce
que je crois que vous m'avez pas compris
il n'est pas question
de supprimer la recette des
collectivités locales
et il y aura de l'octroi de mer pour
protéger c'est le sens de ce que je
propose les productions locales
et il n'est pas question
ou plutôt il est question qu'une partie
de ce qui pourrait s'appeler une taxe
sur la consommation soit dans les mains
des collectivités locales je le répète
s'il y a changement ça reste dans les
mains des collectivités locales
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure je le redis
c'est une rumeur
portée
par des intérêts économiques
qui veut garder de l'octroi de mer alors
qu'il ne produisent rien
gardons l'octroi de mer pour protéger
les productions locales
et s'il y a une introduction d'une taxe
à la consommation le projet qu'il soit
dans les mains des collectivités locales
ça n'a rien à voir avec la TVA nationale
d'ailleurs il faudra pas l'appeler thé
vert sinon ça ne marchera pas et ça sera
pas compris
sur la réforme des niches de l'impôt sur
le revenu intervenu la loi de finances
en 79 en 2019 la mesure vous l'avez dit
c'était 70 millions d'euros à peu près
ça a été entièrement rebuté
pour le FEI le fond exceptionnel
d'investissement qui est passé de 40 à
110 millions d'euros tout est revenu
très directement très directement pour
des investissements de service public
dans les collectivités outre-mer
tout est revenu dans les collectivités
outre-mer au même moment du budget
ça me paraît essentiel et c'est ce que
[Musique]
elle je travaille beaucoup avec les
collectivités locales puisque c'est eux
les bénéficiaires heureusement qu'il est
là sans des millions j'en demande un
bout de dégel là c'est avec ça qu'on
fait
de l'eau en Guadeloupe qu'on fait des
routes qu'on fait tout un tas de sujets
qu'on répare
les équipements publics tout ça la
demande des élus
cet argent a été rendu aux élus
cet argent a été rendu aux élus je
l'affirme haut et fort et il me demande
si j'ai les sous je donne à la fin quand
il y a plus de sous j'essaye de choisir
le plus efficace pour la vie des
ultramarins
était précise ça veut dire que ce SCI
n'est pas particulièrement fléchés vers
les territoires
il est sur l'ensemble des territoires
d'outre-mer d'accord
le FEI
que ça soit très clair
c'est que vous avez profité de baisser
la dotation de l'État donc la solidarité
nationale donc la péréquation pour faire
payer par les territoires d'outre-mer
eux-mêmes le fond d'investissement
exceptionnel jeudi que la Guyane et
Mayotte bénéficie beaucoup plus en
volume parce que ils ont des difficultés
aussi plus importantes mais ça n'enlève
rien sous les difficultés de la
Martinique de la Guadeloupe et de la
réunion avec les taux de pauvreté les
plus exceptionnellement haut les
problématiques de chômage les
problématiques de précarité et pourtant
on augmente les impôts
de ces territoires là c'est ce que je
dis et on a profité pour baisser la part
de dotation de l'État pour faire
financer cette solidarité par les
outre-mer eux-mêmes entre eux
pour 70 millions il y a que 40 millions
de dotation d'étapes parce que 110 70
proviennent des impôts et donc 40000 oui
mais c'est bien ce que je vous dis vous
avez substitué la solidarité nationale
ou la question la péridation par une
solidarité ultramarine entre nous
et en réponse que les transferts
financiers de l'État aux collectivité
d'outre-mer augmente j'ai pas envie de
le dire parce que je trouve ça pas bien
de le dire mais vous me forcez à le dire
les transferts de l'État aux
collectivités d'outre-mer n'ont pas
baissé ils ont augmenté de 2,4 milliards
d'euros en 2013 à 2,18 milliards d'euros
2022 9% d'augmentation et je dis que ce
qui a été pris au territoire d'outre-mer
a été rendu au territoire d'outre-mer
pas au même globalement l'État n'a pas
prélevé de l'argent puisqu'il a aussi
tôt rendu il l'a aussitôt rendu et je
précise j'en profite pour dire que je me
félicite car c'est 110 millions de FEI
se sont ajoutés 97 millions de fonds
verts et qui je pense augmentera sera au
moins pérennisé l'année prochaine et
Dieu sait si on travaille bien ça veut
dire que j'ai à peu près 200 millions à
disposition des collectivités locales
pour répondre à leur demande précise
d'investissement alors demande précise
d'investissement c'est pas et c'est
libre d'emploi c'est voilà donc ça me
paraît
ça me paraît intéressant d'avoir
ce papier ce versement de 100 millions
sur l'inflation vous dites l'inflation
va s'accélérer pour reconstituer les
stocks mais moi votre
différence je rapporter chef d'un
éternel optimisme je me bats et je ne
vois pas pourquoi vous êtes dites
l'inflation va augmenter qu'est-ce qui
vous fait dire ça
débat politique on fait tout à Chichi
attendez vous avez dit l'inflation va
augmenter et ben je réponds vous n'en
savais rien ça dépend des mesures qu'on
prend ça dépend des mesures qu'on prend
ça dépend de l'action qu'on mène ça
dépend de la création de valeur mais
dire a priori je sais que le l'inflation
va augmenter
permettez-moi d'en douter quand c'est
dit avec une telle force d'affirmation
il me semble en tout cas c'est toute
l'action que nous menons ensemble
d'ailleurs pour que l'inflation
n'augmente pas j'ai laissé réagir de
rapporteur parce que je crois que
je voulais dire c'était un effet quasi
mécanique
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que dans nos
territoires vu l'exécuter des marchés
les problématiques d'approvisionnement
et d'accessibilité
dans tous les domaines il y a des zones
de stockage qui sont plus importantes
c'est stocks étaient plein avec des
produits achetés à des prix anciens donc
quand il y a eu une augmentation de
l'inflation ce qui s'est passé c'est que
on a utilisé les stocks les stocks sans
augmenter les prix mais on a consommé
tous les stocks aujourd'hui il y a plus
de stock donc il faut reconstituer les
stocks
reconstituer les stocks à des prix qui
eux ont augmenté considérablement donc
quand aujourd'hui on va se retrouver
avec des stocks de prix augmentés
nécessairement il y aura une
répercussion je ne suis pas en train de
le vouloir je suis en train de dire que
c'est mécanique la question c'est
avez-vous anticipé cette problématique
de reconstitution des stocks avec des
produits plus chers donc qui seront
nécessairement
au coût de revient plus cher et donc qui
vont nécessairement augmenter encore à
la clientèle avez-vous anticipé et
quelle mesure avez-vous pris pour faire
face à cette situation qui est quasi
mécanique
je ne crois pas la mécanique
deuxièmement cette crise elle dure
depuis 2020
depuis 2020 et il n'y a pas eu
d'augmentation du fait de l'augmentation
des prix du fait de la recréation des
stocks depuis 2020 ça fait deux ans
heureusement qu'il y avait des stocks
donc je ne suis pas
de votre avis et en tout cas ce que je
sais c'est que face à ça il y a le bqp
qui fait baisser les prix qui fait
baisser les prix notamment la réunion
sur un certain nombre de produits pas
sur l'ensemble sur un bruit donc je suis
pour une action volontariste
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire sur
l'ensemble des sujets mais je ne suis
pas pessimiste comme vous on peut se
tromper mais qui aura raison le
pessimisme ou l'Optimisme l'optimisme de
l'action
face à la mécanique qui dit que ça
augmente comme ça parce que
un monsieur Ratenon j'ai envie de dire
c'est pas si c'est vous monsieur
j'ai bien envie de trouver mais je
verrai le rapport vous allez faire
l'idée d'une étude extérieure sur
l'accumulation des marges me semble une
bonne idée c'est vous qui l'avez proposé
qu'on réfléchisse ensemble à comment on
fait
a priori c'était un peu votre boulot ici
quand même et on n'arrive pas vraiment
de trouver la vérité on n'arrive pas à
vraiment trouver la vérité elle est
diverse la vérité est-ce qu'il y a
accumulation des marges il y a un
endroit où il y a accumulation des
marges je pense que c'est quand la
marchandise arrive au port
je lui dis comme je le pense je pense
que les transitaires
là il y a une accumulation de marge
sur lesquels notamment en Martinique et
en Guadeloupe on essaye de travailler il
y a des marges qui ne me semblent pas
se justifier en tout cas c'est
accumulation on va voir ce que vous
direz là-dessus à Madame Bassir les
jeunes franches c'est oui
zone franche à l'export ou à la
fabrication locale et à l'export et il y
a des demandes
dans tous les territoires dans chacun
des territoires et on y travaille avec
chacun des territoires dans certains
territoires se baignant on se demande où
on va la mettre il y a des débats pour
savoir où c'est qu'elle doit être
ils avaient divergent entre les élus
vous le savez il faudra trouver un
chemin d'entente là-dessus parce que je
pense pas qu'il soit
utile dans dans faire deux
il me semble
sur la compétitivité renforcée
c'est-à-dire une baisse des charges liée
à la concurrence
je pense que c'est la responsabilité du
donneur d'ordre aussi j'ai pas bien
compris comment comment ça marche ça
d'ailleurs ça n'a pas marché pour être
honnête mais
d'entreprises aujourd'hui et notamment
du secteur du BTP de bénéficier des
compétitivité renforcés pour pouvoir
continuer à produire et à embaucher
c'est un vrai problème aujourd'hui pour
ce secteur
renforcée c'est quand vous êtes soumis à
la concurrence internationale ce qui est
pas le cas du BTP le problème du BTP
c'est les normes on l'a dit vous l'avez
tous dit et c'est des normes qui sont
insupportables mais ils sont pas
vraiment soumis à concurrence
internationale
oui d'accord mais pas par la pas par le
système de la compétitivité renforcée et
dès le BTP dans mon esprit c'est les
normes les normes et les normes où on
est mauvais
c'est une demande je pense
mais mes chers
nous avons là qui parle de la vie chère
mais aussi de l'action de l'État sur les
territoires soit une forme de comment
dire de près des bas budgétaires et
c'est d'ailleurs je pense tout à fait
légitime que ce soit comme ça mais son
jeu qu'il y aura des terres et qu'il y a
des demandes qui vont être portées à ce
moment-là donc on n'aura peut-être pas
toutes les réponses au même moment je
laisse je me suis le ministre
le 3 juillet j'envisage
de réunir déjà réuni les deux les deux
groupes
parlementaires
de délégations pardon
j'envisage de les réunir à nouveau une
fois que mon dossierium est à peu près
calé parce qu'il évolue tous les jours
malheureusement les demandes des
ajustements
et j'envisage aussi de réunir les
exécutifs des territoires de chacun des
territoires pour vérifier avec eux et
leur expliquer
[Musique]
ce qu'il y a dedans et comment on peut
éventuellement le bouger
sur les échanges avec les pays voisins
c'est un des points forts de ce que
j'essaye de mettre aussi un
c'est pas possible c'est très compliqué
c'est un sujet très compliqué
y compris ça supposera vraisemblablement
des changements institutionnels mais je
les proposerai
il faut que
je européens un peu compliqué c'était à
Saint-Martin que d'être un peu loin de
votre lieu de mandat j'avais dit
pourquoi on fait pas des échanges libres
entre Saint-Martin et anguille c'est à
500 mètres ou 800 mètres
mais voilà partie comme un bleu et on me
dit eh ben d'accord il faut que tu
changes le Traité des 27 pays européens
avec Henri durée 4-5 ans quoi et puis ça
n'arrivera jamais
ça n'arrivera jamais donc il faut
arriver à se battre
sur chacun des sujets
sur des adaptations des normes
européennes je vous parle pas des
combats menés sur l'aide à la
réhabilitation des bateaux de pêche
sur le financement
du quai de Lava
on a un vrai sujet et je vais souvent à
Bruxelles
président de la République s'en est
mêler lui-même
on a un vrai sujet de prise en compte
plus plus profonde
des Outre-mer
ça ne peut pas être que je te donne un
peu de fait Ader un peu de FEDER et un
peu de fait en panne c'est ça je crois
ça le fait pas ça suffit pas
derrière on a un vrai sujet de
l'adaptation des normes européennes
juste sous le foncier parce que c'est
une problématique qui se pose avec
beaucoup d'acuités
les prix du foncé qui forme dans
certains territoires qui devenaient
inaccessibles et le prix de rapporteur
interroger aussi sur le quatrième
compagnie aérienne donc ce sont les deux
questions qui restent
sur les compagnies j'en ai déjà trois
je parle des Antilles il y en a déjà
trois qui me demandent de l'argent tous
les matins
pour continuer à faire le job non
donc si j'en ai quatre je suis pas sûr
que ça arrange la mécanique
[Musique]
essayons d'en préserver au moins deux ce
sera déjà pas mal elle perdent toutes de
l'argent sur les Antilles
comme ça après il gagne pas le taux de
rentabilité qu'elles ont ailleurs donc
d'où la réflexion
dont la seule solution me semble-t-il
c'est le prix du kérosène mais quatre
compagnies voilà 3 j'arrive pas à les
sauver
4 je sais pas comment ça va faire
sur le foncier sujet à la
Martinique
avec lequel je travaille pas mal avec le
président les chimie là-dessus on a
d'abord toute la problématique de la
régularisation
historique des indivisions et d'accord
partis j'avais dit avec Serge décimi
j'ai proposé aussi je pense que ça va le
faire un approfondissement de ce truc
pour aller plus loin et plus vite la
ferme semble bouclée le deuxième sujet
qui me préoccupe c'est le fait que
les comment qu'on appelle ça les
affaires ne préampent pas par
partie il faut que les affaires
ça fait aujourd'hui si vous avez elle ne
joue que sur la totalité me semble-t-il
de la propriété si vous
extiltré si vous coupez votre propriété
là ça fait un lino je joue pas dans ces
conditions ça c'est pas possible donc il
faut jouer sur les affaires la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'en Guyane on a
progressé je pense ça y est les
opérationnel dès qu'on aura l'agrément
l'initiat des finances j'espère dans les
trois mois maximum en tout cas le deal
qu'on a qu'on s'est fixé avec le
président servile et la présidente
nouvellement élue de la SAFER et sur le
foncier
c'est un sujet sur lequel j'ai pas de
vrais solutions sur lequel on a une
vraie discussion alors d'abord toutes
les terres littorales enfin les bandes
littorales sur lesquelles ça devrait
donner un peu d'air il faut nous donner
de l'air sur ses capacités lorsqu'on
peut pas c'est pas dangereux
et qu'on peut rester qu'on reste puis
qu'on soit financé aussi sur ces lorsque
vous êtes évacué de la bande littorale
c'est toutes les problèmes des terres
agricoles sur lesquels me semble-t-il il
faut que les affaires puissent
intervenir plus
plus souplement puisqu'on va dire
c'est toutes les successions et les
problèmes d'indivision de succession
qu'il faut faciliter pour l'instant j'en
suis là mais l'info que je peux vous
donner c'est que c'est un des vrais
sujets de travail en commun avec chers
et chimie
j'ai une petite dernière comme
vous avez répondu sur le fait qu'il y
ait la nécessité d'avoir une étude sur
les marges pour autant le réparateur
vous demandez aussi est-ce qu'on peut
dynamiser un peu l'action de l'Autorité
de la concurrence et qu'elle puisse
avoir son rôle de d'enquête qui soit
enfin le déclenche davantage c'est ces
investigations
sur
l'affaire de la concurrence moi mon
sujet il est pas sur l'autorité de la
concurrence il est sur l'alerte de me
donner la déesse
et si j'allais sur la DGCCRF on transmet
d'abord ils peuvent transmettre
directement à l'Autorité de la
concurrence et moi je peux le
transmettre aussi donc le premier sujet
que je vous sur lequel je vais avancer
je le répète c'est une existence plus
prononcée
de l'action de la DGCCRF sur l'ensemble
de ces territoires ultramarins
mais j'ai un contact régulier avec le
président Benoît curé de l'Autorité de
la concurrence
et ce qui demande au gouvernement
est en général et traduit positivement
pour l'instant il me demande pas des
choses extraordinaires
j'ajoute que sur l'autorité de la
concurrence pardon pour faire unique
l'Autorité de la Concurrence a rendu 160
depuis 2019
160 avis sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
plus de 10% concernés
les territoires du travail
je crois que sur avait une
question qui restait en pendante
que j'ai répété deux fois
monsieur le ministre vous m'avez pas
répondu sur l'expérimentation
à Mayotte et en Guyane et la possibilité
d'extension dans les autres pays
français d'outre-mer notamment
l'article 63 de la loi égalité réelle
non elles n'ont pas été mise en
œuvre
à Mayotte et en Guyane sur les deux
endroits où c'était le cas je le dis je
sais pas pourquoi je le
je vais le regarder pour être honnête on
peut pas tout savoir mais sur Mayotte
c'est des accords précis sur le sujet
qui ne préoccupe à savoir l'eau où ça
marche sans que j'ai des décisions
administratives à prendre ça va bien
plus vite
je crois que la question était sur
l'extension de toute façon
moi je veux bien regarder je le note
c'est le sujet sur lequel je suis le
moins averti je le reconnais le moins
averti sur cette outil dans les mains du
préfet pour bloquer un certain nombre de
prix
bien je pense que vous
aurez à coeur à répondre à ces de façon
écrite à cette à cette question et donc
vous nous transmettrez les éléments
évidemment ils seront ils seront
diffusés à l'ensemble des membres de la
commission il est 16h54 donc nous avons
légèrement mordu sur le l'horaire qui
avait été prévu mais je pense que
c'était nécessaire
évidemment nous vous demanderons de bien
vouloir nous adresser des réponses
écrites au questionnaires qui vous a été
envoyés ainsi qu'aux autres questions
qui ont été abordées cette fois-ci le
les députés présents auront tout loisir
évidemment de compléter ces questions
par d'autres interrogations si le
souhaitent
mes chers collègues la séance est donc
levée et les auditions de nos auditions
continueront demain à 8h en entendant le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
vous avez en quelque sorte je pense déjà
essuyé les plâtre une partie des
questions et je ne doute pas qu'elle
revienne demain matin je vous remercie
donc la séance est levée